Well, listen, I'm really thrilled to be here with you two today. I didn't think I was going to make it. What happened? JB was, he was close. He almost didn't make it through the weekend. And then the doctor, they decided to revive him with two almonds. Brought him back to life. And they come in and they go clear, pop, pop.
听着，我今天能和你们二位在一起真的太高兴了。我还以为我来不了了。怎么回事？JB他，他情况挺危急的。他差点没挺过这个周末。然后医生，他们决定用两颗杏仁把他抢救过来。把他从鬼门关拉了回来。然后他们走进来，喊着：让开，砰，砰。
I was a little lightheaded yesterday, but two nuts in my mouth really, they fix a lot. Brought you to life. I know how you feel. Welcome to Smart Life. Smart. Lightest. Smart.
我昨天有点头晕眼花，但嘴里塞了两颗坚果真的，它们解决了很多问题。把你救活了。我懂你的感受。欢迎来到《聪明人生》。聪明。最轻。聪明。
Lightest. Smart. Smart. Smart. Lightest. Smart. Smart. Lightest. Smart. Smart. Hey JB, JB before Rob, little Rob show yourself again real quick. Just let's see Arm Yarv. And he said JB Rob says, Toshan I've got your favorite sports team on my hands.
最轻。聪明。聪明。聪明。最轻。聪明。聪明。最轻。聪明。聪明。嘿，JB，在罗布之前，小罗布快再展示一下自己。让我们看看Arm Yarv。他说：JB，罗布说，托山，我手上拿着你最喜欢的运动队呢。
It says spaghetti. That's very good. That's fun. Isn't that fun? It's fun. It's good clean fun. It is good clean fun. So good morning. Good morning, Jason. First things first. Please, you know I'm obsessed with medical stories.
上面写着意大利面。那太好了。很有趣。不是很趣吗？很有趣。这是健康无害的乐趣。确实是健康无害的乐趣。大家早上好。早上好，杰森。首先第一件事。拜访，你知道我对医疗故事着迷。
Please tell me what happened to you three, four days ago. Oh. Well, I'm obsessed with medical stories, please tell me what happened to you three, four days ago. Oh, well, I'm still in it, unfortunately. You still feel like crap? Well, it's just the things, things are loose, okay? Oh, Jesus. And, you know, I think what it is, God bless my wife, she is more on top of the health stuff than you are even,
请告诉我三四天前你发生了什么。哦。好吧，我对医疗故事着迷，请告诉我三四天前你发生了什么。哦，好吧，不幸的是，我还在经历中。你还是觉得糟透了？好吧，就是有些情况，情况不太对劲，好吧？哦，天哪。而且，你知道，我觉得是这样的，上帝保佑我的妻子，她在健康方面比你还要上心，
which I guess is not that high of a bar to leap over considering you mainline meatloaf and everything. But she gave me this, some sort of supplement for longevity, right? It's like a peptide or something or other. New? Huh? New or been taking it?
我想这并没有多难超越，考虑到你把肉卷当主食而且百无禁忌。但她给了我这个，某种长寿补充剂，对吧？就像是一种肽还是什么乱七八糟的东西。新的？啊？新的还是已经在吃了？
No, no, no, yeah, just a couple of weeks ago. And then she had me take even a little bit more last weekend and that's what did it. I'm pretty sure that's it. For sure, well, first of all, we ruled out immediately food poisoning. Because it would have had to have been bad lettuce. Well, because you would have had to eat.
不，不，不，是的，就几周前。然后上周末她让我稍微多吃了一点，就是那个搞的鬼。我很确定就是这个。当然，首先，我们立即排除了食物中毒。因为那必须是坏了的生菜。好吧，因为你得吃。
Eat, eat. So that's off the table. I know. I mean, it was like the flu, the flu, like if you'd had like a stomach bug, it would have moved through you by now. No, it's still, yeah, I'm fatigued and I can't eat. And like, and look how puffy my eyes are too. It's like, whatever this thing is, like I gotta stop it,, I'm fatigued and I can't eat. And look how puffy my eyes are too.
吃，吃。所以这不可能。我知道。我的意思是，这就像流感，流感，如果你得了肠胃感冒，现在早该过去了好吗。不，还是，是的，我很疲惫，吃不下东西。而且，你看我的眼睛肿得有多厉害。就像，不管这东西是什么，我得停下来，我很疲惫，吃不下东西。看我的眼睛肿得有多厉害。
It's like, whatever this thing is, I gotta stop it, which I'm doing. Yeah, you're okay, very good. It'd be great if the longevity thing killed you. I mean, I just. She did say she got a deal on it. But. Well, I'm glad you're feeling better than you were before.
就像，不管这东西是什么，我得停下来，我也正在这么做。是的，你没事，非常好。如果长寿这玩意儿能把你弄死就太棒了。我是说，我只是。她确实说过她买的时候打折了。不过。好吧，我很高兴你感觉比以前好一些了。
Yes, oh yeah, yeah, I had to cancel a day of work. I haven't done that for a long time. But you guys are very, very sweet. You're just, you know, you guys are a couple of the good ones. I don't care what they say. And you're incredible at reading ads. Did you guys just win an award for your ad reading?
是的，哦，是的，是的，我不得不取消了一天的工作。我很久没这么做过了。但你们真的，真的很贴心。你们只是，你知道，你们绝对是少数几个好人。不管别人怎么说。而且你们太擅长读广告了。你们刚才是不是因为读广告赢得了一个奖？
Did you guys? I think we all did. Why? Well wait, am I a part of it? Yeah. You wanna get to our host? Yeah. Okay, great.
你们是不是？我想我们都有。为什么？等等，我是其中的一部分吗？是的。你想请出我们的主持人吗？是的。好的，太棒了。
And so, you know, this guy is a media titan. He's incredibly smart, incredibly funny. He is responsible for one of my favorite shows. I was very sort of, not nervous, but this show has gone through a couple of hosts and I was hoping that it would land on somebody even better and they have. And he's got multiple irons on the fire.
然后呢，你知道，这家伙是个媒体巨头。他聪明绝顶，幽默风趣。他负责制作了我最喜欢的节目之一。我当时有点，倒不是紧张，但这档节目换过好几个主持人，我当时希望它能落到一个更好的人手上，而他们确实做到了。而且他手头有很多项目在同时进行。
This guy's just, he's cycle high, I think is what they say. He's doing tons of stuff and it's all fantastic. I'm gonna let him tell you about it, but I'm very, very excited he said yes to doing this today. Any guesses? I can't, I have no idea. Me, Chris, Jason, Joseph doing this today. Any guesses? I can't, I have no idea. Me, me, me.
这家伙简直，他现在火力全开，我想他们是这么说的。他在做超级多的事情，而且全都棒极了。我要让他自己跟你们聊聊，但我非常、非常高兴他今天答应来做客。能猜到是谁吗？我不能，我毫无头绪。我，克里斯，杰森，约瑟夫今天来做客。能猜到是谁吗？我不能，我毫无头绪。我，我，我。
Chris, he's, he's, he's, he's, he's, he's, he's, he started in standup. An additional hint. He hosted a political comedy show on Comedy Central. First name starts with T. Last name starts with N. Trevor Noah. Everybody, it's Trevor Noah. It's Trevor Noah. It's. Everybody, it's Trevor Noah.
克里斯，他，他，他，他，他，他，他，他是从单口喜剧起步的。另一个提示。他在喜剧中心频道主持过一档政治喜剧节目。名字以T开头。姓氏以N开头。特雷弗·诺亚。大家欢迎，他是特雷弗·诺亚。他是特雷弗·诺亚。他是。大家欢迎，他是特雷弗·诺亚。
It's Trevor Noah. It's Trevor Noah. It's Trevor Noah. I mean. What's going on everybody? Hey. Hi everybody. From the original, from the original sort of lead in,
他是特雷弗·诺亚。他是特雷弗·诺亚。他是特雷弗·诺亚。我是说。大家好，最近怎么样？嘿。大家好。从最初的，从最初的那种导语，
I thought, or set up, I thought it was like, this is like a newscaster. We got like Walter Cronkite coming in. I was confused for a moment. I genuinely thought it was someone else. Yeah, usually I write these things, but this fricking job I've got in New York, it's really cutting into my prep time. So this interview is going to be even worse than the normal ones.
或者说铺垫开始，我还以为，这就像是个新闻主播。我们好像迎来了沃尔特·克朗凯特。我有一会儿感到很困惑。我真的以为是别人。是的，通常这些东西都是我写的，但我现在在纽约干的这破工作，实在太占我的准备时间了。所以这次采访肯定比平常的还要糟。
Yeah, I was thrown. But then you said the name, then I was like, okay, we're good. You were like, oh, it's me. It's still me. I mean, let's start right there. I mean, did you feel the pressure I felt when you were going in there to take over this incredible show? Yeah. I mean, so here's the thing.
是的，我当时有点懵。但接着你说了那个名字，然后我就想，好吧，我们没事了。你当时就想，哦，是我。还是我。我是说，我们就从这里开始吧。我是说，当你准备去接手这档伟大的节目时，你感受到我感受到的那种压力了吗？是的。我是说，事情是这样的。
When I was going in to take over The Daily Show, I don't think I felt the, I don't think I felt the amount of pressure that I should have felt. Because I didn't grow up with The Daily Show, and I met John Stewart just as a stand-up comedian meeting another stand-up comedian. And I mean, we still talk about that now. Now that John has gone back to hosting the show,
当我准备去接手《每日秀》时，我觉得我并没有感受到，我并没有感受到我本该感受到的那种压力。因为我不是看着《每日秀》长大的，我认识乔恩·斯图尔特时，就只是一个单口喜剧演员遇到了另一个单口喜剧演员。我的意思是，我们现在还在谈论这个。现在乔恩又回去主持这档节目了，
we'll still share the stories of how ironically the other day we were on the phone. And I was saying to him, it's funny that we've gone full circle. When we first spoke, it was on the phone and I was traveling through like Dubai and England doing comedy shows. And then now when we spoke and he's host again, I'm traveling and I was literally in Dubai calling him, having another conversation. It's literally gone full circle. But I wasn't nervous.
我们还是会分享那些故事，比如具有讽刺意味的是，前几天我们正在通电话。我当时对他说，有趣的是我们兜了一大圈又回到了原点。我们第一次通话时，也是在电话里，当时我正游历迪拜和英国等地做喜剧演出。然后现在当我们通话时，他又成了主持人，而我正在旅行，当时我literally（简直）就在迪拜给他打电话，进行着另一场对话。这真的是兜了一个大圈子。但我当时并不紧张。
And then I think after the first few episodes, then the nerves kicked in, which is strange. It's literally gone in a circle. But I wasn't nervous. And then I think after the first few episodes, then the nerves kicked in, which is strange. Normally it's the other way around. Because now you've got a better idea for what it is than you did then. Oh yeah, definitely. And a better idea of how people reacted to it. I think that was the biggest thing.
然后我觉得在前几集之后，紧张感才开始袭来，这挺奇怪的。真的是兜了一个圈子。但我当时并不紧张。然后我觉得在前几集之后，紧张感才开始袭来，这挺奇怪的。通常情况都是反过来的。因为现在你对它是什么比当时有了更好的了解。哦，是的，绝对的。而且对人们的反应也有了更好的了解。我觉得这是最重要的一点。
Because it's so important. It's like this great... It's sort of this Trojan horse that's on a network. It's helping all the medicine go down a little bit easier. The medicine that's so vital for all of us to be taking in. Definitely. What joke really kills in Dubai? Huh, that's an interesting one.
因为这太重要了。它就像是一个伟大的……它有点像是网络里的特洛伊木马。它让所有的良药更容易下咽了一点。那些对我们所有人来说都至关重要的药。绝对的。迪拜什么笑话最卖座？啊，这是一个有趣的问题。
And then tell us what joke you can't tell in Dubai. So what joke really kills in Dubai. So whenever I travel for my shows, it makes it a lot harder, but what I love to do is find comedy that I could only do in that region. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I always try to find something, whether it's an observation, whether it's an experience, but just something that you could only say in Dubai
然后告诉我们你在迪拜不能讲什么笑话。那么什么笑话在迪拜最卖座呢。所以每当我为了演出到处旅行时，这会让事情变得难得多，但我喜欢做的是找到那种我只能在那个地区表演的喜剧。是的，是的，是的。所以我总是试着找一些东西，无论是观察，还是经历，只要是那种你只能在迪拜说的话题，
and then some local not living there would go, wait, what does that mean? So I'll try to tell a few jokes that have like an Arabic punchline or, you know. I'll play with something in that world. I mean, isn't Dubai like that super rich, like aren't they incredibly, isn't Dubai like that super rich, like, aren't they incredibly... Isn't everybody incredibly wealthy?
然后某个不住在那里的本地人会说，等等，那是什么意思？所以我试着讲几个带有阿拉伯语包袱的笑话，或者什么的。我会在那个世界里发挥点什么。我是说，迪拜难道不是那种超级富有，难道他们不是极其，迪拜难道不是那种超级富有，难道……难道不是每个人都极其富有吗？
Let's go for the definition of it. Go ahead, Sean. We're gonna fight it again. Isn't Dubai that kind of wealthy place? Try to be less articulate. Go ahead. Have you ever been outside the United States? Oh, of course. I know Dubai. Sure, of course. What kind of jokes do you tell about...
让我们回归它的定义。说吧，肖恩。我们又要吵起来了。迪拜难道不是那种富有的地方吗？尽量说得没那么流畅一点。说吧。你离开过美国吗？哦，当然。我知道迪拜。当然，当然。你讲过什么关于……的笑话？
Isn't like every single human being there super wealthy? I know Dubai, I was just wondering like, what kind of jokes do you tell about, isn't like every single human being there super wealthy? Yeah, well I mean the Emiratis are pretty wealthy, but then most of the audiences is expats. I think it's like 90%, yeah, 90%. It's one of the most diverse audiences you'll perform for. Oh, that's so great, I love that. Did you ever get up there when you were coming up
难道那里的每一个人都超级富有吗？我知道迪拜，我只是在想，你讲过什么关于……的笑话，难道那里的每一个人都超级富有吗？是的，好吧，阿联酋本国人挺富有的，但大部分观众都是外派人员。我想大概有90%吧，是的，90%。这是你将要面对的最多元化的观众群体之一。哦，太棒了，我喜欢这样。你当年在南非崭露头角的时候，有没有去过那里，
in South Africa, did you ever get up there when you were coming up in South Africa? Did you ever get up there and were any of your dates up in that area? Oh yeah. Yeah. Like when I had to take over the Daily Show, I had to let go of a bunch of dates that were happening around the world. So I just got a foothold into touring all over the, you know, all over the planets. I've had to do that a lot, let go of a lot of dates all over the, you know, all over the planets. I've had to do that a lot, like go over a lot of dates
你在南非崭露头角的时候，有没有去过那里？你有没有去过那里，你在那个地区的演出日期多吗？哦，是的。是的。就像当我不得不接手《每日秀》时，我不得不放弃世界各地的好多场演出。所以我当时刚刚在全世界，你知道的，全世界各地开始有了一席之地进行巡演。我不得不经常这么做，放弃全球各地的很多演出，你知道的，全世界各地。我不得不经常这样做，放弃很多演出，
all over the globe. Yeah, I know. Because I'm just, meh, because I just didn't want to, because I didn't want to seem like. I want to know, you know, when you first came on the scene. Why is the sky blue? Sorry, was that not it? Yeah, that's not it.
遍布全球。是的，我知道。因为我只是，呃，因为我不想，因为我不想显得像。我想知道，你知道，当你刚崭露头角的时候。为什么天空是蓝色的？抱歉，刚才那个不对吗？是的，那不对。
That's because it's a reflection of the. Ocean. Ocean, yeah. So, Trevor, when you first came on The Daily Show, that was my first discovery of you. I was like, oh, what a glorious, wonderful discovery of this man. But before that, bad on me, I didn't quite know.
那是因为它是……海洋的倒影。海洋，是的。所以，特雷弗，当你第一次来到《每日秀》时，那是我对你的第一次发现。我当时想，哦，多么辉煌、美妙的发现啊，发现了这个男人。但在那之前，怪我孤陋寡闻，我不太了解。
So like where you came from or what you're. No, should you know, yeah. So what was life before that and what led you to getting that job? It's funny, you know, I'm never offended by that and I don't know why. Some people apologize for that. Again, I find it's quite common for people to say that in America. They'll say, I'm sorry, I didn't know you.
所以你来自哪里，或者你……不，你应该知道的，是的。所以在那之前的生活是怎样的，是什么让你得到了这份工作？有趣的是，你知道，我从来没有为此感到被冒犯，而且我也不知道为什么。有些人会为此道歉。再说一次，我发现在美国人们说这话很常见。他们会说，对不起，我以前不认识你。
Strange, strange thing here. Because it's such a massive platform. We feel badly that we didn't follow your career before you got the big surely you don't know somebody before you know them That's how knowing people works. I'm always I'm writing that down But now you can't walk down the street, I'm sure Knowing someone were you think I understand he apologized to physics before he learned it? Yeah, right.
奇怪，这里的事情真是奇怪。因为这是一个如此巨大的平台。我们为自己在大红大紫之前没有关注你的职业生涯而感到抱歉。你总不可能在认识一个人之前就认识他吧。认识人不就是这么回事吗。我总是，我正在把这个记下来。但现在你都没法在大街上走路了，我确信。在认识某人之前……你觉得……他在学习物理之前就向物理学道歉了吗？是的，没错。
But you were crushing it in stand-up such that you met with John? Yes. Yeah, so it was really random. I was... So I started comedy in South Africa, performed there my whole life. I was lucky enough that we... What part of South Africa were you... So I was born in Johannesburg, raised in Soweto and Johannesburg, and then that's where I did most of my comedy.
但你在单口喜剧界混得风生水起，以至于你和乔恩见了面？是的。是的，所以这真的很偶然。我当时……所以我在南非开始搞喜剧，在那里演了一辈子。我很幸运，我们……你来自南非的哪个地方……所以我在约翰内斯堡出生，在索韦托和约翰内斯堡长大，然后我在那里做了大部分的喜剧表演。
We didn't have a comedy club, so just to give you a bit of a backstory, I'm assuming you know, but if you don't, so during apartheid free speech was illegal in South Africa, right? And so you weren't allowed to gather, you know, a group of black people weren't allowed to be in one space, and there were all these laws. So stand-up comedy, obviously, you know, is one of the first things that's outlawed in any place that restricts speech.
我们当时没有喜剧俱乐部，所以为了给你们提供一点背景信息，我假设你们知道，但如果你们不知道的话，在种族隔离期间，言论自由在南非是非法的，对吧？所以你们是不被允许聚集的，你知道的，一群黑人是不被允许待在一个空间的，有所有这些法律。所以单口喜剧，很明显，你知道的，在任何限制言论的地方，都是首当其冲被取缔的事物之一。
Wow. So we didn't even have comedy clubs, we didn't have anything. And then once democracy started in 1994, all of a sudden there was just like a boon of new, a boon of people being like, can we sit together? Can we laugh together? God, that must have been exciting. And comedy blew up in the most informal places.
哇。所以我们甚至没有喜剧俱乐部，我们什么都没有。然后一旦1994年民主制度建立，突然之间就涌现出了大量的新人，涌现出大量的人说：我们可以坐在一起吗？我们可以一起笑吗？天哪，那一定很让人兴奋。喜剧在最非正式的地方爆发了。
Comedy was this huge explosion. And you were how old at that time? No, so I only got into comedy. in 94. I'm six years old. I only got into comedy when I was 20 I want to say 21 Okay, and it was it was still nude like that You couldn't make a living from comedy which I which I loved about it It really was something that everyone was doing It wasn't like in the US where people would do comedy so they could get a sitcom, so they could become a movie star.
喜剧迎来了一场巨大的爆发。你当时多大？不，所以我是在94年才开始接触喜剧的。我那时六岁。我是在20岁，我想是21岁时才开始接触喜剧的。好吧，而且它当时还是很新鲜的，你无法靠喜剧谋生，而这正是我喜欢它的地方。它真的是每个人都在做的事情。不像在美国，人们做喜剧是为了能演情景喜剧，为了能成为电影明星。
So no, there it was, you do comedy because you like comedy. There is no part. And also escape the horror of their upbringing. Oh yeah, well I think that's what all comedy is even in the US to be honest with you. Yeah. I think everyone's doing comedy to escape their horrible upbringing.
所以不，在那里，你做喜剧是因为你喜欢喜剧。没有什么别的部分。而且也是为了逃避他们成长过程中的恐怖。哦，是的，好吧，我觉得老实说，美国的所有喜剧也都是为了这个。是的。我觉得每个人做喜剧都是为了逃避他们糟糕的成长经历。
But you actually wrote a book about it too, right? Yeah, yeah I did. Which became a, what did it sell, like three million copies? I don't know, I don't like numbers to be honest with you. It did very well. No, no, no, I mean this honestly, you know why. I don't like numbers when they're good and I don't like them when they're bad.
但你其实也为此写过书，对吧？是的，是的，我写了。那本书成了一本，它卖了多少，大概三百万册？我不知道，说实话我不喜欢数字。它卖得非常好。不，不，不，我是说真的，你知道为什么。我不喜欢数字，当它们好的时候我不喜欢，当它们坏的时候我也不喜欢。
Right, you and me both. Why don't you like them when they're good? Because if you live by the good numbers then you must die by the bad numbers. Absolutely. I think if you're creating, you should just create and then act. I'm so with you then, you're not at the effect of outside circumstances. So Trevor, so walk me through, so you come up in a place that is almost,
对，我和你一样。为什么数字好的时候你也不喜欢？因为如果你靠好数字活着，你就必须为坏数字而死。绝对的。我觉得如果你在进行创作，你就应该只管创作，然后顺其自然。我太赞同你这话了，这样你就不会受到外部环境的影响了。所以特雷弗，那么跟我说说，你成长在一个几乎可以说是，
that has just a very new comedy scene, if you will. Yeah. And now you go, you start touring, you do lots of great stuff, then you take over The Daily Show and you just absolutely explode into the comedy world. When you go back to South Africa, are you, is it safe to say that you're kind of like
刚刚才有了全新的喜剧场景的地方，如果你这么说的话。是的。然后你去了，你开始巡演，你做了很多很棒的事情，接着你接手了《每日秀》，然后在喜剧界彻底大爆。当你回到南非时，你是，可以这么说吗，你有点像是
the first big South African comedy star? Oh yeah. Is there a lot of pressure associated with that? You know what? Not pressure. Not pressure. We... It's so much fun, man. It's hard to explain. So the difference between the two places, I find, in America, fame is almost like royalty. Right. That's why people apologize if they may be unaware
南非第一个真正的大牌喜剧明星？哦，是的。这associated（伴随）着很大的压力吗？你知道吗？没有压力。没有压力。我们……这太有趣了，老兄。这很难解释。所以我发现这两个地方的区别在于，在美国，名气几乎就像是皇室一样。没错。这就是为什么如果人们之前可能不知道，他们会道歉
if you had some beforehand. Yes. I was not aware that you were off your car. I apologize. My liege. Silence, Dave! In South Africa, it's just like people know you. Everyone just treats you like you're part of a big family. That's how it feels. And was it equally welcoming when you came back and you were now famous? Or were they like, oh, were they sort of circumspect and like, let's see if he changed?
如果你之前有些名气的话。是的。我之前不知道你是个大咖。我向你道歉。吾王。闭嘴，戴夫！在南非，人们只是刚好认识你。每个人都把你当成大家庭的一员来对待。感觉就是这样。当你回来而且现在已经是大明星时，受到的欢迎程度也一样吗？还是说他们会觉得，哦，他们有点持观望态度，想看看你有没有变？
I was pretty well known before I left South Africa. So it was just like, oh, congratulations, you've gone and put us on the world stage doing something. That's great. Wow. So tell me about, I imagine when you were doing a bunch of touring, you got used to life on the road and all the bumps and bruises that go along with it. And then you got this incredibly prestigious job and I'm sure we're making a whole hell of a lot more money
我离开南非之前就已经挺有名了。所以感觉就像是，哦，恭喜你，你已经走上世界舞台去做点事情了。太棒了。哇。所以跟我说说，我想当你进行大量巡演时，你习惯了路上的生活以及随之而来的所有磕磕绊绊。然后你得到了这份声望极高、我敢确信赚的钱比以前多得多的工作，
than you were before and getting used to thread count, nice candles and soaps and the lot. Thread count. How has it changed you and made you more soft now and it's tougher going back out on the road? I'm sure, you know, I know you're playing arenas and stadiums and stuff, but Ken, is the old Trevor still alive?
并且开始习惯高支纱床单、高级蜡烛和肥皂之类的一切。高支纱床单。它怎么改变了你，让你现在变得更娇气了，再回到路上巡演是不是更艰难了？我确信，你知道，我知道你在体育馆和大型场馆演出之类的地方，但是，年老的特雷弗还活着吗？
It's funny, my life went the other way around. When I first started The Daily Show, I was actually earning less than I was doing stand-up around the world. I was working hard and I was doing pretty well. So it was really taking the job because of the challenge and the opportunity. As for the thread count, I think my life became a little bit worse because now I was in New York in the winters, walking down the street in like a mini blizzard,
有趣的是，我的人生轨迹恰好相反。当我刚开始做《每日秀》时，我赚的钱其实比我在世界各地演单口喜剧时还要少。我当时工作很努力，而且做得相当不错。所以我接下这份工作纯粹是因为挑战和机遇。至于高支纱床单，我觉得我的生活反而变得更糟糕了，因为当时我在冬天的纽约，走在大街上仿佛身处小型暴风雪中，
walking down like 11th Avenue. I don't know if you've been to the Daily Show studios in New York, it is one of the worst parts of New York. Like in one of the worst parts ever. And it's not like worst part just to clarify for the listener, in that it's dangerous, it's just more that it's shitty. It's really shitty. Dangerous would be better because then it means
沿着第十一大道走。我不知道你们有没有去过纽约的《每日秀》工作室，那是纽约最糟糕的地段之一。就像是有史以来最糟糕的地段之一。为了让听众听明白，这并不是指它有多危险，而更多是指它真的很烂。真的超级烂。如果说它危险反倒还更好一些，因为那意味着
people are there to do something to you. Yes, exactly. It's like a barren wasteland of nothingness. It is such a fucking nothing area. Yeah, it's just a pocket of nothing. So tell us about the meeting with John and how that whole sort of idea sparked in John and how he approached you
有人会在那里对你做点什么。是的，完全正确。就像是一片虚无的荒原。那地方真他妈是个虚无之地。是的，那只是一小片虚无。所以跟我们聊聊跟乔恩的会面，以及那个想法是怎么在乔恩脑子里萌芽的，他是怎么联系你的，
and what that conversation was like. So I got a call. I was, you know, it's one of those moments where you remember exactly what was happening, but not because of how momentous it was in that moment, rather because of how random the thing is that I was doing. I was in London. I was doing my first tour of the UK.
当时那场对话是怎样的。所以I got a call（我接到一个电话）。我当时，你知道，那是那种你确切记得当时在发生什么的时刻，但不是因为那一刻有多重大，而是因为我当时在做的事情有多么随机。我在伦敦。我正在进行我的第一次英国巡演。
And on this particular day, I was standing in Harrods, the mega department store that sells everything. And when I say everything, I mean everything. You all probably know it. And I couldn't afford anything in Harrods. Maybe like, you know, maybe some of the croissants, I don't know. And I was standing in front of an underwater moped. Like a, you know, like an underwater scooter thing, like you ride it like a motorbike but underwater.
就在这一天，我站在哈罗德百货里，那是那个什么都卖的超级百货公司。当我说是每样东西时，我是指每样东西。你们大概都知道。而且我在哈罗德里什么都买不起。也许，你知道，除了几个牛角面包吧，我不知道。当时我正站在一辆水下轻便摩托车前。就像是一辆，你知道的，像是一个水下滑板车一样的东西，你像骑摩托车一样骑它，但在水下。
I have one. Yeah, don't bore Will, he's got one for him and all four boys. Wait, an underwater moped, okay. Yeah, yeah, like you see, this is what my brain was doing. At that exact moment, my brain was doing the same thing. I was just standing there staring at it going What is this? Why is this and why don't I try and get one and hold your breath while you ride the bike? No, it has a little bubble, you know like those old those old
我有一辆。得了吧，别烦威尔了，他和他的四个男孩一人有一辆。等等，水下轻便摩托车，好吧。是的，是的，你看，这就是我当时脑子里在想的。就在那一刻，我的脑子里也在想同样的事情。我只是站在那里盯着它，心想：这是什么？这到底是什么，为什么我不试着弄一辆，然后骑车时还得憋气？不，它有一个小气泡，你知道就像那些老式……
Sky, what do you call it? Like the diving before they had the tanks? Bubble over your belt. It has that It's a bubble over your head. And then my phone rang, some long number, I had no clue what, and I answered the phone, because I don't owe anybody money. And the voice on the other end was like, hey, is this Trevor? And I was like, yeah, and he's like, hey, this is John Stewart. I was like, okay. And he's like, yeah, not really, maybe, I don't know. And he's like, well, I work on a show called The Daily Show. And I was like, oh, I think I've heard of that.
天哪，你们叫它什么来着？就像有氧气瓶之前的潜水？腰部以上有个气泡罩。它有那个。头上罩着一个气泡。然后我的电话响了，是一个很长的号码，我完全不知道是谁，我接了电话，因为我又没欠谁钱。电话那头的人说：嘿，这是特雷弗吗？我说：对，他说：嘿，我是乔恩·斯图尔特。我说：好吧。然后他说：对，也不全是，也许吧，我不知道。接着他说：嗯，我在一个叫《每日秀》的节目工作。我说：哦，我好像听说过。
Because I had seen it on CNN International, because we didn't have it on other channels in the world. And I was like, oh, yeah, I've heard of it. And he's like, oh, as you should have, young man. He's very funny, you know John. Yeah, I love John. Yeah, and then he invited me, you know, he's just like, come and hang out, I think you're funny,
因为我在CNN国际频道上看过，因为世界上其他频道没有这个节目。我说：哦，对，我听说过。然后他说：哦，你本来就该听说过，年轻人。他非常幽默，你们懂乔恩的。是的，我爱乔恩。是的，然后他邀请我，你知道的，他就是那种：来玩吧，我觉得你很幽默，
and I like the way you see the world. Come and hang out with me when you get a chance. And so at first I said no. I was like, I've got the tour. And he's like, are you saying no? What did he say? He said, are you saying no to the trappings of American fame and popularity? Who are you, young man?
而且我喜欢你看待世界的方式。有机会的话来找我玩。所以起初我拒绝了。我说：我有巡演呢。然后他说：你这是在拒绝吗？他当时说什么来着？他说：你是在拒绝美国名气和人气的诱惑吗？年轻人，你以为你是谁？
I said, no, I've got a tour. I'll see you when I see you. And he said, well, if you're in New York, look me up. And I said, definitely. Thanks for the call. It's nice to hear from you. And then I went to New York, I think six months or eight months later, he called me again. He's like, I hear you're in town, but you didn't look me up. And I was like, oh, Jesus, this guy's relentless.
我说：不，我有巡演。回见吧。然后他说：好吧，如果你在纽约，来找我。我说：一定的。谢谢你的电话。很高兴听到你的声音。然后我去了纽约，我想是六个月还是八个月后，他又打电话给我。他说：我听说你在城里，但你没有来找我。然后我想：哦，天哪，这家伙真够死缠烂打的。
So you hadn't told your agent about this phone call, who would have probably... No, I think they gave him my number because they were like, it's John Stewart. What if you had hung up the phone with John Stewart and then the woman at the desk at Herod said, sir, your underwater moped has been paid for by Mr. Stewart. You're like, fuck, I gotta go do this. This guy's a baller.
所以你之前没有把这通电话告诉你经纪人，否则他可能会……没有，我想是他们把我的号码给他的，因为他们觉得：那是乔恩·斯图尔特。如果你挂了乔恩·斯图尔特的电话，然后哈罗德百货的前台女士对你说：先生，您的水下轻便摩托车已经被斯图尔特先生买单了。你就会想：操，我得去干这活。这家伙太牛了。
This guy, yeah, I gotta go. I mean, then you say yes immediately, right? Yeah, of course. Yeah, then it's like a full on. So he tracks you down eight months later in New York. Yeah, and then. He says, come have coffee. He said, come to the show and hang out.
这家伙，是的，我得去了。我是说，那你马上就答应了对吧？是的，当然。是的，然后就完全是……所以八个月后他在纽约追踪到了你。是的，然后。他说：来喝杯咖啡吧。他说：来节目看看，随便逛逛。
Just hang out, and that's all I did. I went there, we hung out. I remember them talking about like John Boehner or something and then I was like, what is this world? What is going on here? So you had no idea about the political landscape in America? I knew the larger, the larger, you know, in the rest of the world, we keep up with American politics, you know, on a big scale.
就只是随便逛逛，这就是我所做的一切。我去了那里，我们闲逛。我记得他们当时在聊约翰·博纳什么的，然后我想：这是什么世界？这到底是怎么回事？所以你对美国的政治格局完全没有概念？我知道大局，大局是，你知道的，在世界其他地方，我们对美国政治有所了解，从宏观层面上。
But the finer minutiae, you know, filibustering and, you know, no. Sorry to interrupt again, but the John Boehner story, wasn't about him crying in some kind of like hung over with like red wine on his teeth. Yeah, I think it was then. It was around that point. Yeah, okay. So you didn't really learn all the specific small-time cretins that populate the house? No, no, no. I did not. Gotcha.
但更细枝末节的，你知道的，阻挠议事之类的，没有。抱歉再次打断你，但约翰·博纳的故事，难道不是说他在某个场合哭得梨花带雨，牙齿上还沾着红酒渍吗？对，我想就是那时候。差不多是那个时候。好吧。所以你其实并没有去了解那些充斥在国会里的形形色色的小政客？没有，没有，没有。我没有。明白了。
We'll be right back. Thanks to Viori for supporting the show. Are you tired of uncomfortable workout clothes? Look no further than Viori. Everything is designed to work out in but doesn't look or feel like it. Their clothes are so comfortable you'll want to wear them all the time. They've taken the activewear world by storm with their high quality and stylish designs. Whether you're hitting the gym, going for a run, or just running errands, they have the perfect outfit for you. Whether you're hitting the gym, going for a run, or just running errands,
我们马上回来。感谢Viori对本节目的支持。你厌倦了穿着不舒服的健身服吗？找Viori就对了。他们的每一件衣服都是为运动设计的，但看起来和穿起来却一点也不像运动服。他们的衣服太舒服了，你会想一直穿著它们。凭借高品质和时尚的设计，他们风靡了整个运动休闲服饰界。无论你是去健身房、跑步，还是只是跑腿办事，他们都有适合你的完美服装。无论你是去健身房、跑步，还是只是跑腿办事，
they have the perfect outfit for you. For me, I've recently discovered, and now enjoy tremendously, the Sunday Element hoodie. Why? Because in LA, it's kind of hot during the day, but it gets really cold at night. So to wear a hoodie all the time, it's like it takes care of all the weather problems
他们都有适合你的完美服装。对我而言，我最近发现了Sunday Element连帽衫，现在爱不释手。为什么？因为在洛杉矶，白天有点热，但到了晚上真的很冷。所以随时随地穿一件连帽衫，它能解决这里的各种天气问题。
here in LA. Because it's thin enough to wear during the day, and thick enough to keep you warm at night. I just love it. Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up smartless listeners with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartless and discover
因为它的厚度白天穿足够轻薄，晚上穿又足够保暖。我太喜欢了。Viori是对你幸福感的一项投资，他们正为SmartLess的听众提供首次在Viori.com/smartless购物八折的优惠。网址是V-U-O-R-I点com斜杠smartless。你不仅能享受首次购物八折优惠，还能享受任何美国境内满75美元订单的免运费和免费退货服务。访问Viori.com/smartless，探索
the versatility of Viori clothing. Go to Viori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. We get support from Helix. We've talked a lot about Helix and for good reason. I have the dusk lux and I sleep like a baby. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress than by sleeping on it in your own home. That's why they offer a hundred night trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty. So how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Well, their team created a Helix sleep quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. And your mattress is shipped straight to your door free of charge. I took the quiz and like
Viori服装的多功能性。访问Viori.com/smartless，探索Viori服装的多功能性。我们得到了Helix的支持。我们讨论过很多次Helix，这是有原因的。我用的是dusk lux床垫，我睡得像个婴儿一样香。Helix深知，测试新床垫的最好方法就是躺在自己家里的床上亲自体验。这就是为什么他们提供100晚的试睡体验以及10至15年的保修服务。那么，你如何知道哪款Helix床垫最适合你和你的身体呢？很简单，他们的团队创建了一个Helix睡眠测试，帮助你在两分钟内找到你的完美床垫。而且你的床垫会直接免费送到你家门口。我做了测试，就像
I said, I got matched with the Dusk Lux because I wanted that medium feel like just like Goldilux which just perfect because I'm on my side a lot and I'm but I also kind of move around But it's perfect for me. It's like they read my mind Helix is offering 30% of all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners go to helixsleep.com Smartless that's helixsleep.com Smartless this is their best offer yet and it won't last long with helix better sleep starts now won't last long with Helix, better sleep starts now. Smart List is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment
我说的，我匹配到了Dusk Lux，因为我想要那种中等硬度的触感，就像金发姑娘里那样刚刚好，这简直太完美了，因为我经常侧睡，而且我也喜欢翻身，但它对我来说简直完美。就好像他们读懂了我的心思一样。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单七折优惠以及两个免费枕头，请访问helixsleep.com/smartless，也就是helixsleep.com/smartless，这是他们有史以来最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久，选择Helix，优质睡眠从现在开始。不会持续太久，选择Helix，优质睡眠从现在开始。SmartLess部分内容由Audible为您呈现。Audible让您在一个应用中尽享所有音频娱乐内容。
in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. They offer an incredible selection of audio books across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment
您总能找到自己挚爱的好书，或者发现全新的精彩内容。他们提供涵盖各个流派的令人惊叹的有声书选择，从畅销书和新书上架到名人回忆录、悬疑惊悚片、励志健康、商业等等。Audible是您享受惊悚音频娱乐的首选目的地，
with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. For me, I just recently watched The Shining, a movie that I've always loved
为每一种类型的惊悚片迷提供备受期待的新书推荐和下一本收听建议。作为Audible会员，您可以从整个目录中每月挑选一本图书永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。对我来说，我最近观看了《闪灵》，这是一部我一直深爱的电影，
that was actually a book first. And I wanted to know how the book was different from the movie, if at all. So I started listening to The Shining. It's narrated by Campbell Scott and it's really really good and it kind of augments what's already great in the movie. So it's really really cool to listen to something of a movie that I already love. It's really really interesting. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500
而它其实是先有书的。我想知道原著小说和电影有什么不同，如果有不同的话。所以我开始听《闪灵》的有声书。它由坎贝尔·斯科特（Campbell Scott）旁白，真的非常非常棒，它在某种程度上丰富了电影中已经很棒的元素。所以听一本我本就深爱的电影的原著真的很酷、非常有趣。新会员可以免费体验Audible 30天。访问audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless至500-500。也就是audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless至500-500
to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. All right, back to the show. What year did you come to the US? I think this was 2015. So 2015 and then you're doing a comedy tour, John Stewart's hassling you, and at the time, what kind of comedy stuff were you into? So you know, this is actually interesting. I remember somebody asked me, they said to me,
即可免费试用Audible 30天。Audible.com/smartless。好了，回到节目中来。你是什么时候来到美国的？我想那是2015年。所以是2015年，然后你在做喜剧巡演，乔恩·斯图尔特在缠着你，当时你比较喜欢哪种类型的喜剧内容？所以你知道，这其实挺有意思的。我记得有人问过我，他们对我说，
when The Daily Show happened, they said, so are you going to, they said, are you a political comedian? You know, the Daily Show is very political. And I said, oh no, no, no, I'm not. I genuinely was like, I'm not a political comedian. I don't even, I don't think of myself that way. When I spent a little time in the US, I came to realize that what I thought of as non-political humor would be considered ultra-political humor in America.
当《每日秀》发生时，他们说，所以你要去，他们说，你是一个政治喜剧演员吗？你知道，《每日秀》非常政治化。我说，哦，不，不，不，我不是。我真的觉得自己是，我不是一个政治喜剧演员。我甚至不，我不觉得自己是那样的人。当我在美国待了一段时间后，我开始意识到，被我视为非政治性的幽默，在美国会被认为是极度政治化的幽默。
Right. Because here the average person doesn't... I think it's changed since Trump, but back when I first got to the US, most people didn't engage in politics. People would literally say, I don't follow politics, I don't get involved, I don't follow politics.
对的。因为在这里，普通人不会……我觉得自从特朗普上台后情况有所改变，但当刚到美国时，大多数人并不参与政治。人们甚至会直截了当地说：我不关注政治，我不掺和，我不关注政治。
Right. Whereas in South Africa, what we consider a basic level of commenting or being involved in the system, we don't think that's political. For us, political is marching in the streets, freeing people from prison, like protesting the system. That's being political. Because in most parts of the world, just being engaged is sort of your civic duty. That's the baseline.
然而在南非，我们认为的对体制进行评论或参与的基本水平，我们并不认为那是政治。对我们而言，政治是走上街头游行，把人们从监狱里解救出来，比如抗议体制。那才叫参与政治。因为在世界大部分地区，仅仅是参与其中可以说是你的公民义务。那是底线。
Right, no matter where you're in South Africa or Dubai, where isn't it full of rich people or something? Anyway. Right, that's the spot. I have to. But I'm so fascinated that John and the rest of the brain trust over there thought that you would be a great choice
对的，无论你在南非还是在迪拜，那儿难道不是到处都是有钱人什么的吗？不管怎样。对，就是那样。我必须。但我感到非常着迷的是，乔恩和那里的其他智囊团认为你会是一个绝佳的选择，
to take over a show that is a mix between comedy and politics politics so it necessitates a full understanding of the comedy world, a full understanding of the political world such that you can blend the two together, find the nuance, find the irony, and wrap it all up in a bunch of jokes for half an hour or more.
去接手一档融合了喜剧和政治的节目，所以它需要对喜剧世界有充分的理解，对政治世界有充分的理解，这样你才能把两者融合在一起，找到微妙之处，找到讽刺之处，并把它们全部包装成一堆笑话，持续半小时甚至更久。
Talk to me about how, did they explain to you what their expectations were and how you needn't worry about not even being from here and haven't lived here in a long time? And how did that go? Well, initially, it was, I always describe the story as feeling a lot like Charlie and the Chocolate Factory. In that I popped in, I had a great time with John,
跟我谈谈，他们有没有向你解释他们的期望是什么，以及你如何不需要担心自己甚至不是本地人、而且很久没在这里生活过？那过程是怎样的？嗯，最初的时候，我总是把这个故事形容得非常像《查理和巧克力工厂》。因为我顺道去了那里，和乔恩度过了一段美好的时光，
and I said to him, I was like, I like what you guys are doing, I guess, but this is not for me. And then we laughed about, we would just, man, because John and I, we get along. You know, there's comedians where you click with them, and your rhythm and your vibe is almost completely simpatico, you're just in it. I'd like to find the person that doesn't get along
我对他说：我觉得你们做的事情挺好，我想是的，但这不适合我。然后我们对此付诸一笑，我们只是，老兄，因为我和乔恩，我们很合得来。你知道，有些喜剧演员，你和他们一拍即合，你们的节奏和氛围几乎完全相通，你们就是能聊到一块去。不过我很想找一个和乔恩·斯图尔特合不来的人。
with Jon Stewart though. I mean he's like an all time great guy. But the comedy is like, you know when it comes to comedy, I find there's a, it's like music. All musicians can play together but some musicians can create magic together and when you find comedians that you share that with, it's pretty special. Yeah, well there's beats and rhythm, go ahead. can create magic together and when you find comedians that you share that with, it's pretty special.
我的意思是，他简直是有史以来最棒的家伙。但喜剧就像是，你知道的，说到喜剧，我发现有一种，它就像音乐。所有的音乐家都能一起合奏，但有些音乐家能一起创造出魔法，当你找到与之共享这种默契的喜剧演员时，那就非常特别了。是的，好吧，这里有节拍和节奏，请继续。能创造出魔法，当你找到与之共享这种默契的喜剧演员时，那就非常特别了。
Yeah, well there's beats and rhythm. Go ahead. As you can see, I'm still looking. We've got them on a separate volume control. I'm still on server. Don't worry. Sean, real quick, Sean, Sean, real quick. Any follow-up questions about the chocolate factory?
是的，好吧，有节拍和节奏。请继续。如你们所见，我还在找。我们给他们设置了单独的音量控制。我还在线呢。别担心。肖恩，快点，肖恩，肖恩，快点。有什么关于巧克力工厂的后续问题吗？
It's not a real place, but if you have anything that you'd like to... Isn't that full of people who like chocolate? I have a thousand questions about the chocolate factory. Oh my God. Last night I made an ice cream sundae and I didn't have any whipped cream, so I made whipped cream. Oh my God, are you writing a screenplay about it now? Hey, Trevor, would you venture to say that actually
那不是个真实的地方，但如果你有什么想……那里面难道不全是喜欢巧克力的人吗？我对巧克力工厂有一千个问题。哦天哪。昨晚我做了一个冰淇淋圣代，但我没有奶油，所以我自己打了奶油。哦天哪，你现在是在写关于它的电影剧本吗？嘿，特雷弗，你敢不敢说其实
coming here, kind of a follow up to what Jay was saying, that being an outsider gave you your perspective almost a bit of an advantage, I would suggest, because you don't have American politics or what we've sort of takes for granted as to how the system works and what the dynamics are between the different, the left and the right if you will, just to make it as basic as possible, because you come in with a different perspective.
来到这里，某种程度上承接了杰森刚才的话，作为一个局外人给了你独特的视角，这几乎算是一种优势，我个人认为，因为你没有美国政治的包袱，或者说我们理所当然认为的体制运作方式以及不同派别之间（如果你愿意的话，为了把它说得最基本一点，也就是左翼和右翼之间）的动态关系，因为你是带着不同的视角进来的。
And you just take it as face value, like oh this is a clown show, as opposed to being somewhat padded with understanding the whole political system and that it's kind of a joke anyway. So I think it was a massive disadvantage and an advantage. The disadvantage is people don't like anyone who doesn't look like them or sound like them coming to tell them anything about them.
你只是以客观的面目看待它，比如：哦，这是一场小丑秀，而不是带着对整个政治体系的理解以及它无论如何都像是个笑话的那种铺垫。所以我觉得这既是一个巨大的劣势，也是一个优势。劣势在于人们不喜欢任何长得不像他们、声音不像他们的人来对他们指手画脚。
So I spent weeks getting random death threats and letters. People hated how I said controversy. And then it was, you know... The word controversy? Yeah, controversy. But did you really get death threats, Trevor? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. That's, I mean... That's quite... It's like, it's powerful, the course I've learned.
所以我花了数周时间收到各种随机的死亡威胁和信件。人们讨厌我发“controversy（争议）”这个词的音。然后就是，你知道的……“controversy”这个词？对，controversy。但你真的收到过死亡威胁吗，特雷弗？哦，是的，是的，是的。那是，我是说……这挺……这就像，我学到的一课，真是威力惊人啊。
As soon as you comment on American politics in a public forum, that's pretty much what happens to you. So that was a disadvantage. Here's something I don't get about the whole phoning in or emailing in a threat. A bomb threat or a death threat. Like, aren't those the exact kind of threats you don't need to really worry about because who the hell would warn you before they play? Like, I don't... I'm certainly not belittling it whatsoever,
只要你在公开场合评论美国政治，差不多就会遭遇这种事。所以这是一个劣势。有一点我一直搞不懂，就是关于打电话或发邮件威胁这回事。炸弹威胁或死亡威胁。比如说，这不正是那种你根本无需真正担心的威胁吗，因为谁特么会在动手前先警告你？我是说，我绝没有贬低的意思，
but I'm always like, I can't believe that someone will clear out an entire office building if they get a bomb threat. It's like, well, if they wanna put a bomb in there, they're probably just gonna do it and not tell you about it. So they're- The irony that you look so much like Ted Kaczynski right now while you're saying this is fucking killing me.
但我总是觉得，我简直不敢相信有人会因为接到一个炸弹威胁，就把整栋办公楼的人都疏散。这就像是，好吧，如果他们真的想在那里放炸弹，他们可能直接就放了，根本不会事先告诉你。所以他们的——你现在说这话的时候，看起来简直太像泰德·卡钦斯基了，这讽刺感简直把我笑死了。
I know. No, I just, you know, I get that they've got to empty the building for insurance reasons, because there's going to be a record that they received the threat, but. So to that, did you ever feel genuinely threatened in a way that was not just a sort of a random kind of. I'm sure, of course. I don't know, I mean it's...
我知道。不，我只是，你知道的，我理解他们出于保险原因必须清空大楼，因为他们得留下收到威胁的记录，但是。说到这个，你有没有过真正感到受到威胁的时候，那种不只是随随便便、偶然遭遇的感觉？我肯定有，当然。我不知道，我是说这……
Scary. Yeah, there's a latent level of anxiety that comes with anybody threatening you. And again, I need to state, I don't think it's that uncommon. I'm pretty certain all the other late night hosts have gotten death threats. It's just, it varies varying degrees. Kimmel gets one a day, I think. I've threatened Kimmel twice this week already myself. On the beginning of Will and Grace,
很吓人。对，任何受到威胁的人心中都会有一种潜在的焦虑感。再说一次，我得声明，我觉得这并不算太罕见。我很确定其他所有深夜秀主持人都收到过死亡威胁。只是，程度有所不同而已。我猜吉米大概一天收到一个。这周我自己就已经威胁过吉米两次了。在《威尔和格蕾丝》刚开播的时候，
we used to get death threats all the time. Ah, there you see. In 1998. So back then, but was that like people sending- Just for shitty jokes or? Yeah. Yeah. People. You know, we have fun, Trevor. We do.
我们以前经常收到死亡威胁。啊，你看。在1998年。所以那时候，但那是人们发——就为了些烂笑话吗？对。对。人们。你知道的，我们只是在找乐子，特雷弗。我们是的。
We just have fun. No, that was because, wait, what was the question? What were the threats about it? Will and Grace. Oh no, yeah, they were written on, yeah, people took the time to sit down. There's one, this one real, this wasn't a death threat, one of the greatest letters we ever got was, I'm not sure what you're talking about. I'm just reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments.
我们只是在找乐子。不，那是为了，等等，问题是什么来着？威胁是关于什么的？《威尔和格蕾丝》。哦不，对，它们是用，对，人们花时间坐下来写的。有一封，这封真的——这不是死亡威胁，我们收到过最棒的信之一是，我不太确定你在说什么。我只是在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。
I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments.
我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。
I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. I'm reading the comments. But this one woman wrote in and she said, you know, we're all going to hell. You should be ashamed for putting this on television. You are all horrible people.
我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。我正在看评论。但有一位女士写信说，你知道的，我们都会下地狱。你们把这种节目搬上电视，真该感到羞耻。你们全都是可怕的人。
But I love the show, I just don't know what, I just don't like what it's about. Oh wow. And could you send me an A510? Yeah. Can I get some tickets for the April 12th show? That's the craziest thing. That's so fucking crazy.
但我很喜欢这个节目，我只是不知道，我只是不喜欢它的内容。哦，天哪。能不能给我一张A510票？对。能帮我弄几张4月12日演出的票吗？这太疯狂了。这简直太特么疯狂了。
I guess it stands to reason that you would get threats. I mean, do you get threats immediately upon doing it? I guess I'm sure that a lot of the threats were, we can all take our pick what they could be about. You're a lefty, right? You're a liberal or? Well, and also you were in, I mean, 2015, I mean, the kerosene had been put on the dumpster
我想你收到威胁也是理所当然的。我是说，你一干这个就会立刻收到威胁吗？我想，可以肯定的是，很多威胁的内容——我们都可以猜到它们大概是关于什么的。你是个左翼，对吧？你是个自由派，还是？嗯，而且你当时身处，我是说，2015年，煤油已经泼在了垃圾桶上，
and it was about to burst in flames. That's exactly it. 12 months later. It was the beginning of Donald Trump and everything that America now lives in as a normal state. Yeah. So that was the majority of your material and so they're going after the person that's in there.
而它眼看着就要爆发熊熊烈火了。正是这样。12个月后。那是唐纳德·特朗普登场的时候，也是美国如今作为一种常态所处的那个世界的起点。嗯。所以那是你绝大部分素材的来源，于是他们就把矛头指向了身处其中的那个人。
I mean, think about that. So you're right. You started, you came to America, as Jason's right at the beginning of the, they were just putting the kerosene, the kindling on the dumpster fire that we all now live in. That's been your experience of America. Let me just say, we've had some good times here, dude. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
我是说，想想看。所以你说得对。你刚开始，你来到美国时，正如杰森所说，正值他们把煤油、把引火柴扔向我们如今身处的那场垃圾桶大火的初期。这就是你对美国的体验。我只想说，我们在这是有过一段好时光的，老兄。对。对，对。
I'm now amended with it. If I get the time machine, what I'm doing is I'm grabbing Trevor and I'm taking him back to like the mid 90s into the mid 2000s. Because we had a lot of fun. It looked like a lot of fun. It really was. I don't want you to get the wrong impression. Happy days are here again soon, I promise.
我现在对它进行了修正。如果我有一台时间机器，我要做的事就是抓住特雷弗，把他带回90年代中期到2000年代中期。因为我们当时玩得很开心。看起来真的很有趣。确实如此。我可不想让你产生错误的印象。美好的日子很快就会重现，我保证。
It's also wild that people, instead of just not watching you, or listening to this or watching that or whatever, they take the time to watch it and then comment on it. Just turn the channel. Instead of just turn the channel, yeah. Yeah, but you know, at the time, it was so hard launching The Daily Show
同样疯狂的是，人们与其选择不看你，或者不听这个、不看那个或别的什么，却偏要花时间去看，然后再发表评论。直接转台不就行了。与其只是转台，对。对，但你知道，在当时，筹备《每日秀》是如此艰难，
that I actually preferred having those people than not. I was like, okay, we have these people... You've got an enemy. No, not even an enemy. I was just like, we have viewers. These people are passionately watching the show and we need every single person to watch. So there was actually one guy I reached out to. There was a guy who was tweeting vitriol at me on the daily, he was like, you know, you're a piece of trash
以至于我其实更希望有那些人，而不是没有。我当时想，好吧，我们有这些人……你有个敌人。不，甚至算不上敌人。我只是觉得，我们有观众。这些人正在狂热地观看这个节目，我们需要每一个人都来看。所以其实曾有一个家伙，我联系过他。有个家伙每天都在推特上对大放厥词，他说，你知道的，你就是个垃圾，
and you'll never make it, and if I ever meet you in the streets, and I DM'd this guy and I said to him, hey man, I just really want to understand, like why do you hate me so much? I've never met you, I've never said anything about you or your life, I'm just trying to understand this.
你永远不会成功的，如果我在街上遇到你，然后我私信了这个家伙，我对他说，嘿，老兄，我真的很想了解，你为什么这么恨我？我从来没见过你，我也从未说过关于你或你生活的任何事情，我只是想弄明白这一点。
And I've never seen a faster switch of tone. He immediately was like, oh, hey, dude, oh, it's not personal and I have nothing against you. I just thought it was funny to pile on. And he said, in all honesty, I have nothing against you. I actually think you're quite funny, but I don't think you're going to succeed. I think the show will fail and you're going to crash and burn.
而我从未见过态度转变这么快的人。他立刻就说，哦，嘿，老兄，哦，这并不是针对个人，我对你没有任何意见。我只是觉得跟着起哄挺好玩的。他说，老实说，我对你没有任何意见。我其实觉得你挺搞笑的，但我不认为你能成功。我觉得这个节目会失败，而你会一败涂地。
And then I said to him, OK, let's make a deal. If I'm still on the air in six months, you'll stay on as a lifelong viewer. And then if I'm gone, I will retweet your tweet and I'll say you were right. And he was like, oh, deal. And then he was like, good luck, man. I'm wishing you the best.
然后我对他说，好吧，我们做个交易。如果六个月后我还在节目上，你就一直做我的忠实观众。然后如果我不在了，我就转发你的推特，并承认你是对的。他说，哦，一言为定。然后他说，祝你好运，老兄。我祝你一切都好。
And then six months later, I DM'd him again. I was like, yo, are you still watching? And he's like, oh, the show's gotten so great. And you know what he made me realize? Crazy, that's gotten so great. And you know what he made me realize? Crazy, that's amazing. No, but you know what he made me realize? I'm honestly eternally grateful to him because he made me realize that most of,
结果六个月后，我又私信了他。我说，哟，你还在看吗？他说，哦，这个节目现在变得太棒了。你知道他让我明白了什么？疯狂，这变得太棒了。你知道他让我明白了什么？疯狂，这太神奇了。不，但你知道他让我明白了什么吗？我老实说，对他永远心存感激，因为他让我明白，美国绝大多数——
not all of, but most of the, just most of the poisonous infighting that you have in America is due to the fact that most people are speaking past each other, not to each other and with each other. A hundred percent. People don't actually engage, people don't see each other as human beings, it's all a theoretical exercise.
虽说不是全部，但绝大多数——美国内部那种充满毒性的内讧，其实都源于这样一个事实：大多数人是在自说自话，而不是在与对方沟通、与彼此交流。百分之百。人们根本没有真正的互动，人们不把彼此当成活生生的人，这一切都只是一种理论上的演练。
But you'll be surprised to find that most people, when you sit down with them and actually, if you're forced to have a conversation where you connect, people start to see each other as humans that exist beyond their political affiliation. A lot of assumptions going on to yeah. Yeah, and it's just a game It's like it's like it's um. It's like sports fans I think American American politics has become like sports where you say everything to the opposing fans But you don't mean it mean it, but you go like this is the purpose of what we're doing
但你会惊讶地发现，大多数人，当你坐下来，真的、如果你被迫进行一次能建立联系的对话时，人们开始把彼此看作是超越政治立场的、有血有肉的人。有很多预设的假设在里面，对吧。对，这只是一场游戏，就像是，就像是，它就像体育迷。我觉得美国的政治已经变得像体育运动一样，你对敌对阵营的球迷说尽所有狠话，
We're here to tell them that they need to die and we want to kill their players Yeah, we hate everything they do and the ref is biased when he rules in their favor. But when you meet in a grocery store, then they're humans because they're doing the same thing. They were basically exaggerating to make a point, you know? But yeah, when you get face to face with it, they get a little bit more real.
但你并不是真的那个意思，你会想，这就是我们这样做的目的。我们来这里就是为了告诉他们，他们该去死，我们想干掉他们的球员。对，我们讨厌他们所做的一切，而且当裁判作出对他们有利的判决时，裁判就是有偏见的。但当你在杂货店偶遇时，他们就成了活生生的人，因为他们也在做同样的事。他们基本上只是为了表达观点而夸大其词，你知道吗？但对，当你面对面接触时，他们就会变得更真实一些。
Yeah, I mean, I hate Manchester City as a football club. Wait, what? Yeah, I mean, I hate Manchester City as a football club. Wait, what? Yeah, I hate Man City. But then I also like, love, but I love Pep Guardiola, and I love Holland, and I love Kevin De Bruyne. Why would you hate, why would you hate, why would you hate all the players? I've never met anybody who has a, like a... Well, because I'm a Liverpool supporter, a massive Liverpool supporter.
对，我是说，作为一家足球俱乐部，我讨厌曼城。等等，什么？对，我是说，作为一家足球俱乐部，我讨厌曼城。等等，什么？对，我讨厌曼城。但与此同时，我也喜欢，热爱，我热爱佩普·瓜迪奥拉，我热爱哈兰德，我热爱凯文·德布劳内。你为什么要讨厌，你为什么要讨厌，你为什么要讨厌所有的球员？我从来没见过谁有这样一种……嗯，因为我是利物浦球迷，一个狂热的利物浦球迷。
I'm a Liverpool supporter, but I don't hate Manchester City. Well, just because they're going to beat us. Yeah, but I mean they've spent the money and it's like, I get annoyed but I... You see it's funny, that's where, like for me the rivalries are more games that I'll think of but Manchester City I find... My point was, I say I hate them but then I like all the players on the team. I like Pep Guardiola, I like Holland, I like De Bruyne, I like Phil Foda, and I like all their players, and so I don't really hate them,
我是利物浦球迷，但我并不讨厌曼城。嗯，那是因为他们要击败我们。对，但我是说他们砸了钱，这就好比，我会感到恼火，但我……你看，这很有趣，对吧，对我来说，竞争更像是我会关注的比赛，但我发现曼城……我的意思是，我说我讨厌他们，但接着我又喜欢队里的所有球员。我喜欢佩普·瓜迪奥拉，我喜欢哈兰德，我喜欢德布劳内，我喜欢菲尔·福登，我喜欢他们所有的球员，所以我并不是真的讨厌他们，
but I have to because they're, I do hate the Boston Bruins, that's a hockey team, that I do. I do hate the Boston Bruins. Fucking send me your letters, I don't give a shit. Fuck you, I fucking hate them more than you fucking, like hate me. Trevor, now have you, have you since now become,
但我不得不这么做，因为他们是，我确实讨厌波士顿棕熊队，那是一支冰球队，那个我是真的讨厌。我确实讨厌波士顿棕熊队。特么的给劳资寄信吧，我才不在乎呢。去你的，我特么讨厌他们，比你们特么讨厌我还甚。特雷弗，现在你，你从那以后，
is following politics a hobby for you now? Do you enjoy it or now that you're out of there? Yeah, you don't need to be in the swamp anymore. So I don't follow politics as a hobby. What I try to do is understand which conversations can exist beyond the noise. You know, I often try and explain to people, when I'm having conversations with them, is... So, the most interesting thing about the US system for me is the fact that it leads people to believe that there are only two ways to do something.
关注政治现在成了你的一个爱好吗？你现在还喜欢它吗？还是说既然你已经离开了那个圈子？对，你不需要再在这个泥潭里了。所以我不再把关注政治当成爱好了。我试着去做的是，去理解哪些对话是可以超越这些喧嚣而存在的。你知道，我经常试图向人们解释，当我与他们交谈时……所以，对我来说，美国体制最有趣的一点在于，它引导人们相信做一件事只有两种途径。
You know, it's Republican and it's Democrat. And I've never understood that framing, to be honest with you. I've never even understood how newspapers will report. And these are like distinguished newspapers. They'll write a story that leads with Democrats win with, and it's a law that's changed. But I go, no, that should just be the law has changed and that should be how you report it.
你知道，要么是共和党，要么是民主党。老实说，我从来没有理解过这种非此即彼的框架。甚至连报纸的报道方式我都从未理解过。这些还都是些声望卓著的报纸。它们会写一篇以“民主党赢得”开头的报道，而内容不过是某项法律发生了改变。但我会想，不，那应该只是报道“法律发生了改变”，这才是你该有的报道方式。
It shouldn't be that it's a win for somebody or a loss for somebody else. It's a lot of the media. It's a lot of the media, how they frame everything. So I follow it now to try and understand where the issue lies and the politics ends. Because issues are real, politics are how we try and solve the issues.
不应该是对某人来说是一场胜利，或者对其他人来说是一场失败。很多媒体都是这样。很多媒体在构架一切事物时都是这个套路。所以我现在关注政治，是为了试着去理解问题究竟出在哪里，而政治又是何时结束的。因为问题是真实的，政治只是我们试图解决问题的方式。
But politics is not real, it's not actually a real thing. But Trevor, and I'm not being coy here at all, maybe this is... I think you've probably noticed in this country certainly, that there's not a lot of appreciation in any aspect of life for nuance in this country. Yeah, you're either on this team or that team. Yeah, and it's very binary, and it's always a sort of a zero-sum game.
但政治本身并不是真实的，它其实不是一个真实的东西。但是特雷弗，我可不是在拐弯抹角，也许这是……我想你大概也注意到了，在这个国家，毫无疑问，在生活的各个方面，人们对细微差别的欣赏都极其匮乏。对，你要么属于这个团队，要么属于那个团队。对，而且非常非黑即白，永远是一种零和博弈。
That is part of the American experience. You win, you lose. There's no nuance. That is true, that is true. I will say, if you want to liken it back to sports, I always say to my American friends, I go, I see why soccer was never the most popular game and might never be.
这就是美国体验的一部分。你赢了，你输了。没有中间地带，没有细微差别。确实如此，确实如此。不过我要说的是，如果你想把它类比回体育运动，我总是对我的美国朋友说，我终于明白为什么足球从来都不是最受欢迎的运动，而且可能永远也不会是了。
It's because in soccer we have a draw. We sometimes say, you know what? Neither team won, neither team lost. This was a great game, everybody go home. It's winners and losers. And so if politics is also about winners and losers, then nobody wants to concede because it automatically means that they've lost. Which isn't a good way to have politics.
那是因为在足球里我们有平局。我们有时会说，你知道吗？两队都没赢，两队也没输。这是一场精彩的比赛，大家都回家吧。但这里只有赢家和输家。所以，如果政治也是关于赢家和输家的，那么没有人愿意妥协，因为那自动意味着他们输了。这可不是一种健康的政治运作方式。
As opposed to compromise. Yeah, politics should never be about winning or losing. It should be about compromising and then, you know, understanding that the majority... It's even stranger. Do you ever think about it, when you look at America's results, I'm always shocked at how states are called blue or red, and then you look at the number, and it's like 51%, and people confidently say, well, that's a red state,
而不是去妥协。对，政治永远不该是关于输赢的。它应该关乎妥协，然后，你知道的，去理解多数人……这甚至更奇怪。你有没有想过，当你看到美国的选举结果时，我总是对各州被贴上蓝色或红色的标签感到震惊，然后你看看那个数字，比如是51%，而人们却信誓旦旦地说，嗯，那是个红州，
and I go like, but it's 49% blue. Right. Or vice versa. Everything's half and half, yeah. Right. Everything's right in the middle, yeah. Well, if you think, and this is true, I think, for politics in general,
而我会想，但那里有49%是蓝色啊。没错。或者反过来。一切都是一半对一半，对吧。没错。一切都正好卡在中间，对吧。好吧，如果你想想，而且这确实适用于一般的政治，
and so I don't mean to come off as completely naive, but the idea that the actual politics are more important than the policy is absurd. All of the politics is supposed to be a mechanism by which we sort of, that sort of drives policy. And that it should be what people are concerned about, what the actual issues are, and they're not. They're much more invested in the game of it,
所以我并不是想显得完全天真，但那种认为实际的政治手段比政策本身更重要的想法简直荒谬绝伦。所有的政治运作本应只是一种机制，用来推动政策的落实。这本该是人们所关心的，本该是真正的议题所在，但他们并不在乎。他们更多地投入到了那场游戏中，
and as you said, the win or lose of the game. Yeah, but a lot of a lot of that I will blame you know to what you said Sean is like I think the media has to take a lot of blame for that because the media has enjoyed turning it into a game and the media has enjoyed turning it into a spectacle and so if they reinforce that narrative then I find lawmakers, you know one of the most interesting turning it into a spectacle. And so if they reinforce that narrative, then I find lawmakers... You know, one of the most interesting experiences I had when I first came to America was I went to New Hampshire
正如你所说，投入到了那场游戏的输赢之中。对，但其中很大很大一部分，我要归咎于——你知道的，就像你刚才说的，肖恩——我认为媒体要为此承担很大责任，因为媒体很享受把它变成一场游戏，媒体很享受把它变成一场奇观，所以如果他们不断强化这种叙事，那么我发现立法者……你知道，当我刚来到美国时，我经历过最有趣的事情之一就是去了新罕布什尔州，
for the primaries. And this is literally, I've been in America for barely a year. Now I'm in New Hampshire, you know, and Vermont and all of these places. And I will never forget seeing, there were two politicians who were, you know, on the stump, and they were giving their speeches, and it was vitriolic, and they were, you know, this person's gonna destroy the country,
去参加初选。那真的可以说是，我到美国甚至还不到一年。现在我身处新罕布什尔州，你知道的，还有佛蒙特州以及所有这些地方。我永远不会忘记当时的情景，有两个政客正在发表竞选演讲，他们舌灿莲花，言辞极其恶毒，他们说，你知道的，这个人会毁了这个国家，
they're gonna do this, they, and then in the evening, I saw them at a diner, and the two of them were sitting together laughing, and they were like, how's your family? How's everything going? Since I was a kid, I don't understand that. Yeah, in many ways it's almost like wrestling. It's like American politics.
他们会干这个，他们会……然后到了晚上，我在一家小餐馆里看到了他们，这两个家伙坐在一起有说有笑，他们问：你家人的近况怎么样？一切都还好吧？我从小到大都无法理解这一点。对，在很多方面，这几乎就像是职业摔角。就像美国政治一样。
You see these people in the ring and it's like, Triple H, I'm gonna rip you limb from limb. And as a fan you're like, yeah, kill him, kill him. And then only to find out that like your favorite wrestler who hates the other wrestler in your mind is actually great friends and is the godfather to their child. I think American politicians don't do a they don't do the country service they do it a disservice by not showing everybody that they do get along that they go out together that they have
你看到这些人在擂台里放狠话，就像是：“HH（Triple H），我要把你碎尸万段！”作为粉丝，你会觉得：对，干掉他！干掉他！然后结果却发现，在你的心目中那个恨惨了另一个摔角手的你最喜欢的摔角手，其实私底下是极好的朋友，还是对方孩子的教父。我认为美国政客没有为国家尽责，他们没有向所有人展示他们其实相处得很好、会一起出去、一起吃饭、是好朋友、还会参加彼此的婚礼，这简直是在帮倒忙。
meals that they're friends they're in weddings. Also like I think language is important too like when you president, Republican or Democrat, says, who's ever in office, they say, well, the Democrats thought blah, blah, blah, or the Republicans thought blah, blah, blah. And it's like, you have to say the Republicans in Congress feel this way, or the Democrats in Congress. So what happens is it generalizes everybody,
还有，我觉得语言也很重要，比如当你的总统——无论是共和党还是民主党——无论谁在台上，他们都会说：“嗯，民主党人认为巴拉巴拉，或者共和党人认为巴拉巴拉。”这就好比，你必须说“国会中的共和党人是这么觉得的”或者“国会中的民主党人”。所以结果就是，这一切把所有人都概括进去了，
well, I'm a Democrat, well, I'm a Republican. You know, now you're telling me that we all think that way? No, it's just the lawmakers think that way. You know what I mean? That's a good point. And also think about the idea that, look, it's the spring of an election year. Of course, and again, at risk of sounding completely naive,
“哦，我是个民主党人”，“哦，我是一个共和党人”。你知道的，现在你在告诉我，我们所有人都这么想吗？不，只有那些立法者才那么想。你知道我的意思吗？这话说得好。再想想这种观点：瞧，这正是选举年的春天。当然了，再次冒着显得极其天真的风险，
of course they have to pit them against each other because they need to drive ratings because we know that all of it is driven by commerce. Everything in this country is driven by commerce. And so if there's no race, if there's no, they have to say so and so is leading by this. If the election were today, these are the weak spots. He's ahead, she's ahead. He's going to crush, he's not going to crush. They have to keep us in the game.
他们当然必须让双方针锋相对，因为他们需要拉高收视率，我们都知道这一切都是由商业利益驱动的。这个国家的每一样东西都是由商业利益驱动的。所以如果没有竞争，如果没有……他们就必须宣称某某某以百分之多少领先。如果今天是选举日，这些就是软肋。他领先了，她领先了。他要大获全胜了，他要惨败了。他们必须把我们留在牌局里。
Yeah, they just have to be more discerning. Yeah, and they just have to be more discerning. Yeah, because they need us to watch the commercials in between. So if you really want to get mad at it, get mad at CNN and MSNBC and Fox and all of them, because they're just, all they're doing is in service of commerce. That's it. Yeah, yeah. It's completely in service of commerce. If I break it down into three levels, I'll go, you know, on the media side, I wish they would stop turning it into the spectacle that they do, but they probably won't, as you say, because the money is there.
对，他们只是需要更有鉴别力一点。对，他们只是需要更有鉴别力一点。对，因为他们需要我们去看中间插播的广告。所以如果你真的想为此生气的，那就去对CNN、MSNBC、福克斯以及所有这些媒体生气吧，因为它们全都在为商业利益服务。仅此而已。对，对。这完全是在为商业利益服务。如果我把它拆解为三个层面，我会说，你知道的，在媒体方面，我希望他们停止把政治变成那种哗众取宠的奇观，但他们大概不会停手，正如你所说，因为利益就在那里。
Or that's what they want to get, you know, once you can make a profit and change everything. Sports get the best ratings in this country. So if they can turn it into a football game, they'll do it. But on the ground as well, I think as people, that's something that I found strange coming to America, is how people would say, I am a Democrat, I am a Republican. And I'd be like, what? What does that mean?
或者说，只要能赚钱并改变一切，那就是他们想要的。体育节目的收视率在这个国家是最高的。所以只要能把它变成一场橄榄球赛，他们就会这么干。但在基层也是如此，作为一个普通人，我来到美国后觉得很奇怪的一点，就是人们会说：“我是个民主党人，我是个共和党人。”我会想：什么？那是什么意思？
Where I come from, people just talk about how they voted, but they are not the thing. And I think if you take yourself away from being the thing, you allow yourself the opportunity to either be disappointed by the thing or step away from the thing when it is necessary. You know, because it shouldn't be a sport, you shouldn't be, like, I am a Liverpool supporter is correct, we will go up and down with Liverpool.
在我老家，人们只会谈论自己投了谁的票，但他们本身并不等同于那个党派。我认为，如果你把自己从那个标签中剥离出来，你就能让自己有机会在必要时对那个党派感到失望，或者从那个党派抽身离开。你知道的，因为这不该是一场体育比赛，你不应该……就好比说“我是利物浦球迷”是没问题的，我们会与利物浦同呼吸共命运。
Whereas in politics you should just say, I voted for this and then I voted against it and it's like, I'm not that thing. Well imagine if you, imagine we lived in a world where you can just, all you did was you weren voting there were there was no such thing as a party and you just voted on issues. Yeah. Right. We'll be right back. Smartless listener, let me tell you about the Defender 110. For those who embrace the impossible, the Defender 110 is up for the adventure. This iconic vehicle has been redefined with thoroughly modern design.
而在政治中，你应该只是说：“我这次投了这个，下次投了那个”，这就好像，我可不是那个党派本身。想象一下，如果我们生活在一个你可以……你所做的只是投票，根本没有政党这种东西，你只根据具体议题投票的世界。没错。我们马上回来。SmartLess的听众朋友们，来听我讲讲卫士110（Defender 110）。对于那些勇于迎接不可能的人来说，卫士110随时准备好迎接冒险。这款标志性的车型经过了重新设计，拥有极其现代的设计感。
The exterior offers compelling proportions while the interior has been built with robust materials and integrity. The Defender's capability is legendary. Whether you're facing off-road challenges or harsh weather conditions, you can rely on their innovative camera technologies to deliver unobstructed views and effortless maneuvering. Plus, their powerful innovations like the intuitive driver display and award-winning infotainment system make sure you stay connected. For me, it seems like the Defender 110 could be used in any state you live in under any weather condition. With weather getting worse and worse, the Defender 110 seems like it's the only car
其外观线条比例迷人，而内饰则采用坚固耐用的材料打造，尽显硬汉本色。卫士的越野性能堪称传奇。无论你面对的是越野挑战还是恶劣的天气条件，你都可以信赖其创新的摄像技术，它们能提供开阔无遮挡的视野，让操控变得轻松自如。此外，诸如直观的驾驶员显示屏和载誉无数的信息娱乐系统等强劲创新功能，能确保你时刻与外界保持连接。对我来说，无论你住在哪个州、面对什么样恶劣的天气，卫士110似乎都能派上用场。随着天气变得越来越糟，卫士110似乎成了唯一一辆
that could handle anything. Ready for a wide range of adventures? The Defender family features the two-door Defender 90, the Defender 110, and the Defender 130, which seats up to eight. Learn more at LandRoverUSA.com forward slash Defender. SmartList is supported by GoodRx. Spring has sprung and so has allergy season. I know Scotty suffers tremendously from allergies during the spring. He's on all kinds of stuff. But when it comes to the cost of your allergy meds and other prescriptions, checking GoodRx can help you save and stay healthy. GoodRx is the free, fast, and easy way to find the prescriptions
能够应对一切状况的汽车。准备好迎接丰富多彩的冒险了吗？卫士家族包括双门版的卫士90、卫士110，以及最多可容纳八座的卫士130。欲了解更多信息，请访问LandRoverUSA.com斜杠Defender。SmartList得到了GoodRx的大力支持。春天已经来临，过敏季节也随之而来了。我知道斯科蒂在春季深受过敏折磨。他吃了各种各样的药。但说到你的过敏药物和其他处方的费用，查看GoodRx可以帮你省钱并保持健康。GoodRx是查找你所需的处方药
you need at a lower price. With GoodRx you can instantly find discounts, compare prices, and save up to 80% at the pharmacy. GoodRx is accepted at all the major pharmacies in your neighborhood including CVS, Walgreens, Rite Aid, Vons, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more. And remember GoodRx works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance, GoodRx may beat your co-pay price. So if you're looking for seasonal allergy relief with low cost prescription medications, GoodRx is a walk in the park for you this spring. For simple smart savings on your prescriptions, check GoodRx is a walk in the park for you this spring. For simple, smart savings on your prescriptions,
以更低价格购买的免费、快速且简单的方法。通过GoodRx，你可以即时找到折扣、对比价格，在药店最高节省80%的费用。GoodRx被你家附近的所有主要药店接受，包括CVS、Walgreens、Rite Aid、Vons、Walmart、Sam's Club等等。请记住，无论你有没有保险，GoodRx都能派上用场。即使你有保险，GoodRx的价格也可能比你的共付额更便宜。所以如果你想在这个春天以低成本的处方药来缓解季节性过敏，对你来说，使用GoodRx简直就像在公园里散步一样轻松。想要在处方药上享受简单、聪明的省钱方式，
check GoodRx. Go to GoodRx.com slash SmartList. That's GoodRx.com slash SmartList. Thanks to Grammarly for their support. With so many emails and so much texting and so much everything going on in your life, it's nice to have something like Grammarly. It really, really works.
请查看GoodRx。访问GoodRx.com斜杠SmartList。也就是GoodRx.com斜杠SmartList。感谢Grammarly对本节目的支持。生活中有着这么多的电子邮件、这么多的短信以及各种各样忙不完的事，能有像Grammarly这样的小助手真是太好了。它真的、真的非常管用。
Sometimes one confusing email turns into 12 confused replies, right? And then a meeting to get aligned, and it's just a pain in the butt. Grammarly is a trusted AI writing partner that saves your company from miscommunication and all the wasted time and money that goes with it. I love that it kind of thinks for you. Grammarly's generative AI prompts help you kind of complete sentences before you even do.
有时，一封让人摸不着头脑的电子邮件会导致12条让人一头雾水的回复，对吧？然后还得开个会来对齐信息，这简直烦透了。Grammarly是一个值得信赖的AI写作伙伴，能让你的公司免受沟通不畅之苦，并省去随之而来的所有浪费的时间和金钱。我特别喜欢它仿佛能替你思考这一点。Grammarly的生成式AI提示甚至能在你动笔之前就帮你补全句子。
And Grammarly helps you strike the right tone by suggesting a better word based on your audience and context. It's pretty futuristic, awesome stuff. When every word your team writes is clear, concise, and on-brand, everything gets better. Teams that communicate better with Grammarly report 66% less time spent editing marketing content and 70% improved brand compliance across the company. Join 70,000 teams who trust Grammarly to work faster, hit their goals, while keeping their data secure. Learn more at Grammarly.com.
而且Grammarly还能根据你的受众和语境推荐更好的词汇，帮你把握恰当的语气。这真的是非常具有未来感、棒极了的功能。当你的团队写出的每一个字都清晰、简练且符合品牌调性时，一切都会变得更好。与Grammarly合作、沟通更顺畅的团队报告称，编辑营销内容的时间减少了66%，全公司的品牌合规性提升了70%。加入7万个信任Grammarly的团队，工作更高效，达成目标，同时确保数据安全。了解更多信息请访问Grammarly.com。
Smart Lessons brought to you in part by Airbnb. I recently stayed at an Airbnb. I was on a golf trip. Can I tell you something? It was fantastic. It was easy and kind of felt like a little bit of a home away from home, you know, I went with my with my buddy JDog, that's all I'll say. It's not not JB. Anyway, maybe you stayed in an Airbnb before and thought to yourself This actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could be an Airbnb You already have an Airbnb
SmartLess部分内容由Airbnb倾情呈献。我最近入住了Airbnb。我去了一趟高尔夫之旅。能告诉你一件事吗？棒极了。既轻松又有点像家外之家的感觉，你知道的，我是和我的死党JDog一起去的，我只能说这么多了。不是，不是JB。总之，也许你以前也住过Airbnb，然后心里想：这其实听起来挺可行的。也许我的房子也可以做成Airbnb，你已经有了一个Airbnb
Airbnb and be it Maybe you're planning a getaway this summer and while you're away You could Airbnb your home and make some extra money to help pay for the trip. That's just math. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. And now back to the show. Noah, so what about hosting?
Airbnb and be it（谐音梗）。也许你正计划在这个夏天度假，而在你外出期间，你可以把自己的房子挂在Airbnb上出租，赚点外快来补贴旅费。这简直就是数学。你的家可能比你想象的更有价值。访问airbnb.ca斜杠host了解具体价值。现在言归正传。诺亚，那么主持呢？
Like do you still want to keep hosting? Is it something like you're like, I did it, I'm moving on to something else? On Airbnb? Oh no. Or like would you, like do you have aspirations to host the Oscars, the Emmy, like award shows or anything? Well, you've done, yeah, the Grammys.
比如你还想继续主持吗？这是那种你会觉得“我已经干过了，我要去搞别的”的事情吗？在Airbnb上？哦不。或者说你会，比如你有野心去主持奥斯卡、艾美奖之类的颁奖典礼或别的什么吗？好吧，你已经干过了，对吧，格莱美。
How many years now? Right? Oh, that's right! I forgot. MTV and... The Grammys has been fun. I've done the Grammys a few times now. Now were you a huge music fan before that?
到现在多少年了？对吧？哦，对哦！我都忘啦。MTV和……格莱美一直很有意思。我已经主持过好几次格莱美了。那你之前是个超级音乐迷吗？
Have you, has your... You mean was I human? That's a strange question. Yeah, exactly. Well, who doesn't like music, Jason? No, but I mean like some people are obsessed with it. Jason doesn't know what humans do, dude. Well, maybe a better question would be, has your passion for music increased since you've
你有没有，你的……你是说我以前是个人类吗？这是个奇怪的问题。对，完全没错。好吧，谁不喜欢音乐呢，杰森？不，但我的意思是有些人对此着迷。杰森根本不知道人类在干什么，老兄。好吧，也许更好的问题是：自从你走到幕后以来，
been behind the curtain? And by the way, I apologize. Of course I've watched it on the Grammys. I completely forgot. No, no, no, no. You know what? Can I... You've established your own right earlier in the show. Sorry, I didn't know you were a host of the Grammys. No, no, no, no. You know what, can I... You've established your own brand earlier in the Grammys. No, no, no, no. Don't do that to Sean, guys.
你对音乐的热情是不是增加了？顺便说一句，我道歉。我当然看过你主持格莱美。我完全给忘得精光。不，不，不，不。你知道吗？我能……你刚才在节目早些时候已经树立了自己的风格。抱歉，我不知道你是格莱美的主持人。不，不，不，不。你知道吗，我能……你刚才在格莱美上树立了自己的风格。不，不，不，不。别那样对肖恩，伙计们。
Don't do that. I know what he means. And I'll tell you why, Sean, it's funny. I don't think the Grammys is the same as like the Emmys or the Oscars or any of those shows because... Well, I'm an actor, so I watch those more. Yeah, but also the Grammys is like hosting a concert. You know, the Emmys and the Oscars and all these other awards, they do feel like an award show.
别那样。我知道他是什么意思。我来告诉你为什么，肖恩，这很有趣。我不觉得格莱美和艾美奖、奥斯卡或任何这类颁奖典礼是一样的，因为……好吧，我是个演员，所以我看的那些更多一些。对，但格莱美也更像是主持一场音乐会。你知道的，艾美奖、奥斯卡和所有这些其他的颁奖典礼，它们确实感觉像是一场颁奖典礼。
The Grammys just feels to me like a concert. Yeah, that's true, that's great. I've definitely developed a greater appreciation for artists. Seeing them rehearse, seeing how hard it is to get everything right, seeing them do it live, that's what's definitely increased. And then also my palettes, like every time I'm at the Grammys, I discover a new artist that I now become a fan of. What about a full genre?
而格莱美对我来说更像是一场音乐会。对，确实如此，太棒了。我对艺术家们的欣赏确实大大加深了。看着他们排练，看着要把所有事情做好有多难，看着他们进行现场表演，这些确实让我对他们的赞赏与日俱增。而且还有我的品味，就像每次我在格莱美现场，我都会发现一个现在成了我粉丝的新艺术家。那整个流派呢？
Like, country, are you a fan of country now? I listen to way more country now than I ever did. You know what I mean? Everybody, like the Lou Combs, you name it. I just got into it because you would hear the song so many times in rehearsal and you'd see how amazing it could be, and then you fall in love with it. That Tracy Chapman performance.
比如乡村音乐，你现在是乡村音乐的粉丝了吗？我现在听乡村音乐比以前多多了。你知道我的意思吗？每个人，比如卢·康姆斯（Luke Combs），应有尽有。我开始迷上它，是因为你在排练时会听到这首歌无数遍，你会看到它能变得多么惊艳，然后你就会爱上它。特雷西·查普曼（Tracy Chapman）的那场表演。
Oh my god, I cried my eyes out. I know. I'm not a huge, a lot of the music at the Grammys is not really my taste generally. It's all kinds of music on the Grammys. But I'm such a like 90s indie rock fan. Oh, right. So they would have awarded your bands years ago. Yeah, if it was like Bill to Spill and Dinosaur Jr. and the Pixies, I would have been like,
噢天哪，我哭得稀里哗啦。我知道。我不太算，格莱美上的很多音乐通常不合我的口味。格莱美上有各种各样的音乐。但我是一个坚定的90年代独立摇滚迷。哦，对。所以他们多年前就会给你的乐队颁奖了。对，如果那是像Built to Spill、Dinosaur Jr.和The Pixies这样的乐队，我就会觉得，
ah, great. But then I watched that Tracy Chapman and you just forget what an unreal fucking talent she is. Yeah, Trevor, what is the phone number that you've gotten from hosting the Grammys all these years that you're most proud of? Which artist? What famous rocker do you now have on your phone? Oh, I don't have anybody's number, to be honest with you. You don't go,
啊，太棒了。但随后我看了特雷西·查普曼的演出，你就会忘记她究竟是个多么不可思议的特么的天才。对，特雷弗，这些年来因为主持格莱美，你得到的哪个电话号码是你最引以为傲的？哪个艺术家？你现在手机里存了哪个著名的摇滚乐手？哦，说实话，我谁的号都没有存。你不会去说，
Hey, hey, hey, it'd be great to hang out. I was in a band, you can have my number. I would gladly take your number. This is a strange thing to say, but like... So I always found it strange that people would try to be friends just because they're in a similar space. So I don't know how to explain it. You're famous, I'm famous, we should hang out.
“嘿，嘿，嘿，能一起玩就好了。我以前组过乐队，你可以记下我的号。”我绝对乐意记下你的号。说这话可能有点奇怪，但是……所以我一直觉得很奇怪，人们会试图仅仅因为身处相似的圈子就去当朋友。所以我不知道该怎么解释。你很有名，我也很有名，我们应该一起玩。
Yeah, but okay, so this is what would happen to me. Alright, you would all probably understand this. I remember when I first came to America and now I would get invited to events But okay, so this is what would happen to me. Alright, you would all probably understand this. I remember when I first came to America and now I would get invited to events because you know, part of the Daily Show and you go to these events and everyone would be like, oh we should hang out. You take my number, take my... Oh my God, Trevor, we got to hang out sometime.
对，但好吧，所以这就是发生在我身上的事。好吧，你们大概都能理解这一点。我记得我刚来到美国时，现在我会收到活动邀请——但好吧，所以这就是发生在我身上的事。好吧，你们大概都能理解这一点。我记得我刚来到美国时，现在我会收到活动邀请，因为你知道，作为《每日秀》的一部分，你去参加这些活动，每个人都会说：“哦，我们应该一起玩。记下我的号，记下我的……天哪，特雷弗，我们抽空得一起聚聚。
We got to get a coffee, we got to get a coffee. This guy's great. We got to get... Let me get your number. Where are you? Oh yeah, I'm there all the time. We got to do it. And I would give people my number and in my head I was like, wow, I'm making so many friends. These people are so friendly, this is amazing. And then I would hear nothing from them.
我们得喝杯咖啡，我们得喝杯咖啡。这人真棒。我们得……把你的号给我。你在哪儿？哦对，我经常去那儿。我们一定得约。我会把我的号给别人，而在我脑海里，我会想：哇，我交到了好多朋友。这些人太友好了，这太棒了。然后我就再也没有他们的音讯了。
I would message them, I would hear nothing, they wouldn't respond at all. People, by the way, people in Hollywood change their numbers all the time. Like, I don't even know who, like, everyone has like a new number all the time. And then what would happen was, this was one of my favorite memories,
我给他们发消息，却杳无音信，他们根本不回复。顺便说一句，好莱坞的人们总是换电话号码。就像，我甚至不知道谁的——每个人总是换新号码。然后会发生什么呢，这是我最喜欢的记忆之一，
I met somebody, and this has happened a few times, I met the same person at another event, maybe like a year later, and they're like, oh my God, Trevor, this is, oh man, how have you been, congratulations, man, we gotta hang out, let me get your number, let me get, and I was like, I think you have my number, and they're like, no, no, no, no, I changed phones and I got a whole day.
我遇到了一个人，这种情况发生过好几次，我在另一个活动上遇到了同一个人，大概是一年以后，他们会说：“哦，天哪，特雷弗，这真是，哦老兄，你最近怎么样，恭喜啊老兄，我们得聚聚，把你的号给我，把你的……”而我会想：“我想你已经有我的号了。”他们会说：“不，不，不，不，我换了手机，我换了新号……”
Didn't your number... I was like, my number didn't change. And they're like, no. And I put my number in on their phone. And you know when you type it in on the screen, then my name just popped up. And I was like, you have my number. I'm like, wait, what? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then what did Justin Theroux do? Oh, let me tell you, okay, I have the greatest And I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that.
难道你的号……我会说：“我的号没变啊。”他们会说：“没有。”然后我把我的号输进他们的手机里。你知道当你在屏幕上输入它时，然后我的名字就跳出来了。然后我会说：“你明明有我的号。”我就像，等等，什么？对，对，对。然后贾斯汀·塞洛克斯（Justin Theroux）做了什么？哦，我来告诉你，好吧，我有最棒的——我不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。
I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that.
我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。
I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to do that. I can't remember yesterday, so chances are high. I was... So I was invited to a... It was a Netflix party before one of the Emmys. It was for like a whole bunch of nominees before the Emmys. And Ted Sarandos was hosting this event, and everyone's gathered. And it was... I mean, it was star-studded. It was crazy. And you don't see these people all the time.
我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我才不打算那么做。我都记不清昨天的事了，所以这种概率很高。我当时……所以我被邀请去参加一个……那是艾美奖前夕的一个Netflix派对。那是为艾美奖前的一大群提名者办的。泰德·萨兰多斯（Ted Sarandos）主持了这个活动，大家都聚集在那里。而且——我是说，那里大腕云集。简直疯狂。你并不是无时无刻都能见到这些人的。
That's the misconception everyone has, that if you're on the same platform, you just hang out. Right, you don't. I was just standing there, you know? And I look across the garden where this event's being held, and I see Jason, and I'm like, oh my God. And I've loved you forever. I go, you're easily one of my favorite comedy performers.
这就是每个人都有的误解，以为只要你们在同一个平台上，你们就会一起玩。没错，你并不会。我当时就站在那儿，你知道吗？然后我穿过举办活动的这座花园，我看到了杰森，我就想：天哪。我一直都超级喜欢你。我说：你绝对是我最喜欢的喜剧演员之一。
I mean, all of you are in different things. Like, Sean, I used to watch Will and Grace with my mom. It's okay. No, no, no. Don't throw the compliments away. I mean it, like literally. The timing, the cadence, the everything. Will, everything you do on like BoJack Horseman.
我是说，你们所有人都活跃在不同的作品里。就像肖恩，我以前和我妈一起看《威尔和格蕾丝》。没关系。不，不，不。别把这些恭维推开。我是认真的，真的。那种时机感、语调、一切。威尔，你在像《马男波杰克》（BoJack Horseman）这样的作品里所做的一切。
So I love comedy. I love the technique. But less, right, with Sean and Will? Yeah, I mean, I mean this honestly. You are easily one of my favorite funny people ever. But at that time, Ozark was just... It was my life. It was the best.
我太喜欢喜剧了，也喜欢这种技巧。不过跟肖恩和威尔在一起时就少了一些，对吧？真的，我是说真的。你绝对是我最喜欢的搞笑人物之一。但当时，黑钱胜地对我来说就是……这就是我的全部生活，太棒了。
Anything I had seen that had flipped the whole genre of like, you know, drugs and everything. One of my favorite comedies too. Timing and... I thought it was very funny actually. So, I see you and you see me standing across the way. And you look at me and you just gave me like a little eyebrow like hello. And I was like oh damn, okay. And so I walked over to you and I said hello and you were very kind.
我见过的任何颠覆了毒品之类传统题材的作品。这也是我最喜欢的喜剧之一。时机，而且……我觉得其实非常搞笑。所以，我看见你，你也看见我站在对面。你看着我，然后冲我挑了挑眉毛，像是在打招呼。当时我就想，天哪，好吧。于是我朝你走过去，跟你打了招呼，你人非常好。
And I immediately went to you. I was effusive. I said I love everything you do and I went and I said you did this. I was likeusive, I said, I love everything you do and I just, I went and I said, you did this and I was like, I love game nights and I love this and I was just listing everything off because I love, I genuinely love them all. And, but then I said, I said to you, I said, oh and most recently you crushed it.
我立刻就走向你，情绪很激动。我说我喜欢你做的每一件事，然后我说你做过这个。我当时很激动，我说我喜欢你做的每一件事，我走到你面前说，你做了这个，我说我喜欢《游戏之夜》，我喜欢这个，我简直把所有作品都列举了一遍，因为我喜欢，我发自内心地喜欢它们全部。然后，接着我对你说，我说，哦，最近你表现太惊艳了。
You know, I didn't think Ant-Man was going to be good and it was phenomenal. And you listened to me break down the whole Ant-Man everything. And then you paused. And I swear it was like you had written this. Your face, you went like, huh. And he said, do you think that I'm Paul Rudd?
你知道的，我原本以为《蚁人》不会好看，结果惊为天人。然后你听着我滔滔不绝地分析《蚁人》的方方面面。接着你停顿了一下。我发誓，那感觉就像你提前写好了剧本一样。你的表情变了变，然后你“哈”了一声。你问我：你觉得我是保罗·路德吗？
And I will never forget that moment and I went, no, I thought that Paul Rudd was you. I gave him, but it's true, I gave him your performance, is how good I think you are. Anything good he did, I was like, it should be Jason Bateman, I guess. I strive to be Paul Rudd. And we just stared at each other awkwardly for a moment, and you said, huh, did you come here because you thought I was someone else?
我永远不会忘记那个时刻，当时我说：“不，我以为保罗·路德是你。”我把……但这确实是真的，我把你的演技安在他身上，可见我对你的评价有多高。他演的任何好作品，我都觉得：我猜这其实是杰森·贝特曼演的吧。我可真想成为保罗·路德。然后我们尴尬地对视了一会儿，你问：“哈，你来这儿是因为你以为我是别人吗？”
And I said, no. But you said Ant-Man. And I said, I would rather say that I'm racist and you all look the same than admit that that happened. And then we just stood there awkwardly for a moment. And you were very nice. We just stood there and I said, well, one day we will meet again,
我说：“没有。”但你提到了《蚁人》。我说，我宁愿承认自己有种族歧视、觉得你们长得都一样，也不愿承认刚才发生了那种事。然后我们俩就在那儿尴尬地站了一会儿。你人非常好。我们就站在那儿，我说：“好吧，总有一天我们会再次相遇的……”
hopefully under different... And what I should have said is, don't worry, I'll never remember this because I know how to pour cement over bad memories. JB, do you remember that? I do not. He doesn't remember anything. By the way, don't take it personally. No, no, no, I'm glad. All I know how to do you remember that? I do not. He doesn't remember anything. Trevor, by the way, don't take it personally.
“希望在不同的情况下……”而我当时应该说的是：“别担心，我永远不会记得这事，因为我知道怎么把这些糟糕的记忆用水泥封存起来。”JB，你还记得那件事吗？我不记得了。他什么都不记。顺便说一句，别往心里去。不，不，不，我很高兴。我只知道怎么……你还记得那事吗？我不记得了。他什么都不记。特雷弗，顺便说一句，别往心里去。
All I know how to do is remember dialogue that my brain at an early age was formed into that being a one trick, I'm a one trick pony. I can remember dialogue. What about a Coke dealer's number? Yeah, yeah, still, do you need some? Yeah, you remember that, yeah, you remember. It's been 20 some years.
我唯一擅长的事，就是记住那些我年幼时就被大脑塑造成“只会这一招”的台词。我只会这一招。我能记住台词。那毒贩的电话号码呢？对，对，依然记得，你需要几个？对，你还记得，对吧。这都过去二十多年了。
Do you remember old dialogue though? No, I have a great delete button too, so that I have room on my drive for tomorrow's. To not remember the other things. Oh, he's one of the all-time great dialogue memorizers. But I will go, I'll go to a movie with somebody and two days later, I'll talk to that person, I'll go, oh, you know what I saw a couple days ago?
那你还记得以前的台词吗？不，我也有一个很棒的删除键，这样我的硬盘里就能腾出空间来存明天的内容了。好不去记别的事情。哦，他可是史上最厉害的台词记忆大师之一。不过我会去……我会和某人一起去看电影，两天后，我会和那个人聊天，然后我会说：“哦，你知道我几天前看了什么吗？”
You got to see this movie. I've done it a dozen times. What does that mean? I do that too sometimes. I'll do it to Scotty. I'm like, I was at this movie, he's like, I was with you. I mean, it's terrible, but maybe it's good because I'm with somebody who feels so comfortable.
“你得去看这部电影。”这种事我已经干过十几次了。这说明什么？有时候我也这样。我会对斯科蒂这么说。我会说：“我去了这部电影院，”他说：“我当时就跟你在一起啊。”我的意思是，这太糟糕了，但也许这也是件好事，因为我和这个人在一起感到无比放松。
I mean, it blocks out the bad memories, right? Early onset? That could be. It could be just a trace. Why are you saying early? You think you're young? I'm not that young. Just let a fucking compliment into yourself? Here's another one, here's another one before you carry on. This was, can I just say, so you know obviously I'm a huge fan of the podcast and I understand the format. But here's the thing, I didn't know that the surprise guest was really a surprise thing.
我的意思是，这能屏蔽掉不好的记忆，对吧？初老症状？有可能。可能只是有一点迹象。你为什么说“初”？你觉得自己很年轻吗？我可没那么年轻。就不能好好接受一个该死的赞美吗？还有这一个，在你继续之前，还有这一个。这可是……我能说吗？所以你知道，显然我是这个播客的超级粉丝，我也理解这里的节目形式。但问题是，我并不知道神秘嘉宾真的是一个惊喜环节。
Yeah. Okay. We didn't know you were going to come on. We've only broken it a couple of times. Yeah, so we were at the Vanity Fair Oscars party. Right. Yeah. And I saw you. And Will walks by, you walk straight to me, but you walk to me with the confidence of somebody
对。好吧。我们之前并不知道你要来。这个环节我们只搞过几次。对，所以我们当时在名利场的奥斯卡派对上。没错。对。然后我看见你了。威尔从旁边走过，你径直朝我走来，但你朝我走来的那种自信，就像是一个……
who knows that I'm coming on to the podcast. And you were like, hey! And then you said, yo, I'm so excited. I was like, oh! And I was like, I'm so excited to chat to you. And then as I said that, Jason was behind you, staring at me like I had killed his whole family.
知道我要来上这个播客的人。然后你走过来喊道：“嘿！”接着你说：“哟，我太兴奋了。”我当时想：“哦！”我说：“我跟你聊天太兴奋了。”就在我说这话的时候，杰森就站在你身后，盯着我，那眼神就像我杀了他的全家一样。
He couldn't hear anything by the way, he was just staring at me and I said, I'm so excited to chat to you about Formula One. And then we started talking about Formula One. Interesting, it was funny that you said that now that I remember you saying that and I was thinking like, man he's really into Formula One, he's really honed in on me on the Formula One and he's been looking. I was panicking, I was like, oh D,'s really into Formula One. He's really honed in on me on the Formula One
顺便说一句，他什么也没听见，他只是死死盯着我，而我说：“我太兴奋了，想跟你聊聊一级方程式赛车。”然后我们就开始聊一级方程式赛车。有意思的是，现在回想起来，你当时说那些话还挺搞笑的，我还纳闷：天哪，他对一级方程式赛车是真爱啊，他居然在一级方程式赛车这个话题上把我拿捏得死死的，而且一直盯着我看。我当时慌了，心想：天哪，D，他对一级方程式赛车是真爱。他在一级方程式赛车上把我死死拿捏住，
and he's been looking... I was panicking. I was like, oh, I screwed the whole thing up. I screwed the whole thing up. And then I was like, oh, let's just get into Formula One. And you did look at me like, man, this guy really went deep into Formula One in the middle of an Oscars party. Right out of the gate. And then you walked away and then Jason came up to me
而且一直盯着我看……我当时慌了。心想：天哪，我把整件事搞砸了。我把整件事全搞砸了。然后我想：好吧，那就直接切入一级方程式赛车吧。而你看着我的眼神确实像是在说：天哪，这家伙在奥斯卡派对的现场居然对一级方程式赛车研究得这么深。一上来就直奔主题。然后你走开了，接着杰森走到我面前，
and he said, please, you didn't say anything. You don't fuck this up. You're the surprise guest. You don't fuck this up. I didn't say anything. I didn't say anything. You don't fuck this up. You're the surprise guest. You don't fuck this up. Fuck this up. I didn't say anything. I didn't say anything. And then he walked away.
对我说：拜托，你什么都别说。你千万别把这事搞砸了。你可是神秘嘉宾。你千万别把这事搞砸了。我什么都没说。我什么都没说。你千万别把这事搞砸了。你可是神秘嘉宾。你千万别把这事搞砸了。搞砸了。我什么都没说。我什么都没说。然后他就走开了。
Did you say that to him, JP? You said hi. Uh-huh. It's funny, I had somebody else at the thing as well. That same night after you, Trevor, I won't say it is, because I don't know whose guest it is, come up to me and it's somebody I've known a long time.
这话是你对他说得吗，JP？你打了招呼。嗯哼。说实话，那天现场还有另一个人。就在你之后不久，特雷弗，那个当晚的同一个人——我就不说是谁了，因为我不知道他是谁的嘉宾——走到我面前，那是我认识很久的一个人。
And I go, what's up, dude? And he goes, I'm coming to talk to you on your stupid podcast and I go well I didn't know that asshole sorry sorry sorry Rockwell did that too poor guy oh yeah Rockwell did you like getting gussied up like that traveling going out by the kind of events. By the way Trev, let me just tell you something. You looked really good on Sunday. I look cool like a guy. Very sharp. Thank you.
然后我说：“怎么了，兄弟？”他却说：“我要去你的破播客上跟你聊聊了。”我说：“好吧，我不知道这混蛋……”抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，罗克韦尔也干过这事，这可怜的家伙。哦，对，罗克韦尔干过。你喜欢打扮成那样到处旅行、出席这种活动吗？顺便说一句，特雷弗，我得告诉你。你周日看起来真帅。我看起来像个酷小伙。非常利落。谢谢。
I've never heard that term gussied up. Gussied up. Yeah, we got some beauties here in this country. You ever been to Illinois? No. No, I've been everywhere actually. No, I do enjoy it. I went to, in South Africa, in school, you wear school uniform your whole life.
我从来没听过“打扮得花枝招展”（gussied up）这个词。打扮得花枝招展。对，我们这个国家可有不少漂亮宝贝。你去过伊利诺伊州吗？没有。没有，其实我哪儿都去过。不，我确实很喜欢。我去过……在南非，上学的时候，你一辈子都要穿校服。
So I actually like dressing up like that because I feel like it's no stress. I go, yeah, you put on the pants, you put on the jacket, and you know you're doing it right. And then you have a good time. Women have it so tough. You gotta find the gown and then those shoes on. Yeah, I wear comfortable shoes. My toes are all individually spaced out. It's wonderful.
所以我其实很喜欢这样盛装打扮，因为我觉得这没什么压力。我说：对，你穿上裤子，穿上夹克，你就知道自己穿对了。然后你就能玩得很开心。女人可太难了。你得去找礼服，还得踩着高跟鞋。对，我穿的是舒服的鞋子。我的脚趾都是根根分开的。太棒了。
I think that when you said women have it so tough, they were expecting something a little more than the shoes and the gown, but OK. Well, in childbirth, I'm fucking with you. This is how we get into it. This is the entree. The stuff they've got to deal with. Trevor, I want to, you know, I brought it up
我觉得当你刚说“女人可太难了”的时候，大家期待的不仅仅是鞋子和礼服，不过好吧。好吧，在生孩子这方面……我开玩笑呢。这就是我们切入正题的方式。这是前菜。她们得应对那些事。特雷弗，我想……你知道的，我刚才在开头谈到非洲时提到了这个，我想知道你多久回一次非洲？我……我从没去过。我也从来没去过。我想回家。我觉得自己一直在亏待自己。我真的很想去。这跟……这跟我收到的大多数恶意邮件里的内容一模一样。
at the start of talking about Africa, and I want to know how often you get back to Africa. I'm so, I've never been. I've never been either. I want to go home. And I feel like I'm depriving myself. I really want to go. This is the same thing. This is the same thing I get in most of my hate mail.
你什么时候回非洲？哦，天哪。哦，不。好吧，我顺便补充一句。我能跟你一起去吗？我想去，因为你有点像那种“大人物”。你经常回去吗？我经常回去。对，我一直在那儿。
When are you going back to Africa? Oh, geez. Oh, no. Well, let me just add to that. Can I go with you? I want to go because you're kind of like the dude. Do you get back often? I go back all the time. Yeah, I'm there all the time.
特别是自从我离开《每日秀》之后，我回去的次数多多了，你知道的，陪陪我妈妈，陪陪家人，我在那儿……我可以说我大概每两、两个月就会回去一次，真的。那太棒了。对，我喜欢……从纽约飞过去要16小时，然后还有20个小时……从洛杉矶出发，这就变成了一段诡异的25小时左右的旅程。所以，对吧，南非航空有16小时的直飞航班，对吧？对，不，不，不，其实现在只有美联航有飞往那里的航班。
Especially since I left The Daily Show, I get to go back a lot more, you know, I spend time with my mom spend time with family I'm there I would say I'm there like every two two months to really That's great. Yeah, I love along the flight 16 hours from New York and then 20 It becomes like a weird 25 ish our journey from From LA. So yeah, 16 hours direct South African airways, right? Yeah, no, no, no, actually United's the only airline that flies there now.
真的吗？对，所以你知道，生活有给予，也有剥夺。对，还有美国，你新收养的家，你通常对它有什么看法？你喜欢它吗？你有最喜欢的地方吗？哦，我太喜欢这个地方了。所以，事情是这样的，对，关于美国，
Really? Yeah, so you know, life giveth and life taketh away. Yeah, and America, your new adopted home, do you generally, what's your take on it? Do you like it? Do you have favorite places? Oh, I love this place. So here's the thing, yeah, here's the thing about America,
我的看法是，再次说明，你知道的，有时缺乏的可能就是细微的差别。我觉得人们把这些视为理所当然：你可以在一个地方生活，既觉得它无比美妙，同时又在很多时候感到失望，这取决于你对它的体验。你知道，有时人们在街上走到我面前，会说：“你这个垃圾，你恨美国，
is I think, again, you see, nuance is maybe what is lacking sometimes. I think people take for granted that you can live in a place where you find it both amazing and at many times disappointing, depending on what you're experiencing of it. You know, people sometimes walk up to me in the streets and they'll be like, you hate America, you piece of trash,
你为什么不滚？”我就想：谁说过我会住在自己痛恨的地方？我们先从这一点说起。其次，我由衷地发现美国的许多地方都非常了不起。而且我发现，那种铭刻在这个国家骨子里的乐观精神，才是我觉得最了不起的地方。你知道，这是一个了不起的国家，黑人在完全没有权利的时候，竟然相信有一条通往平等权利的道路。仅仅这一点，就有一种奇异的乐观精神，我认为这既美丽又深邃。
why don't you leave? And I'm like, who said I would not live anywhere I hate? Let's start with that. Secondly, I genuinely find a lot of America amazing. And I find it's the optimism that is etched into the very fabric of the country that I find amazing. You know, it's an amazing country where black people at a time when they had no rights believed that there was a path for them to get equal rights. Even that is a strange level of optimism that I think is beautiful and profound.
是的，考虑到他们当时的生活状况，确实如此。对，这正是我要表达的。对，它极其雄心勃勃且富有成效。它具备这些特质。我认为这是一种极好的品质，应该永远坚持下去，永远不要丢失。因此，尽管美国有许多缺点，其他国家也有很多。我一直在四处旅行，所以我不抱任何幻想。我不认为美国是最好的，也不认为它是最差的。
Yeah, considering how they were living, yes. Yeah, that's exactly my point. Yeah, it's incredibly ambitious and productive. It has that. And I think it's a wonderful trait to hold on to and to never lose. And so while America has many faults, other countries have many. I travel all the time, so I'm under no illusion. I don't think of America as best or worst.
我只觉得每个地方都有它在当前面临的问题，并在当时去处理这些问题。所以你，对，我知道。美国人以及美国这个地方，以及每个州、每个城市之间的巨大差异，一直有一种特质让我深深着迷，我永远感激能来到这里。你是西海岸的人还是东海岸的人？
I just think every place has the issues that it is dealing with at the time that it's dealing with them. So you, yeah, I know. There's something I've always loved about Americans and America as a place and how different each state and each city is, and I'm eternally grateful to be here. You're a West Coast guy or an East Coast guy?
我两边都待。我觉得东海岸对你的头脑大有裨益，西海岸则对你的身体大有好处。我说的身体不是指体力上，而是那种……我觉得你会呼吸得更顺畅一点，睡得更好，吃得更好，它能带给你一种平静的效果，但东海岸非常适合极大地刺激你的大脑，让你的思维活跃起来。是的，我同意你的看法。有很多……我20岁时从加拿大搬到了这里。
I split it. I find the East Coast is great for your mind, the West Coast is great for your body. And I mean your body not physically, but just like, I feel like you breathe a little more, you sleep better, you eat better, it just has a calming effect on you, but the East Coast is great to get your brain just like really stimulated and going. Yeah, I agree with you. There's a lot in in I moved here when I was 20 from from Canada.
所以其实没那么远。但我确实同意这里有许多美好的事物。我对这个国家也口吐芬芳过很多次。但我在这里住了很长时间。这个国家有太多美好的事物。我同意你的看法。但对我们来说，指出这些问题很重要，对它的缺点保持坦诚也很重要——是的，并且去关爱它。是的，没错，你得把美国想象成一架波音
So it wasn't that far. But I do agree that there's so many great things. And I give this country a lot of shit. But I've been here a long time. And there's so many great things about this country. And I agree with you. But it's important for us to point out this stuff, you to be to be honest about the shortcomings because yeah and to care for it yeah well yeah you've got to think you've got to think of America like a Boeing
飞机，你应该……你应该欣赏它能够飞行的事实，而且它能飞起来这件事本身就相当了不起。我的意思是，这个锡罐能以四万英尺的高空悬浮在天空中，这太了不起了，太疯狂了。但如果你停止关注它，不尝试去不断改进它，那么机门可能会掉落，起落架可能会失灵。轮子会掉落，而且在从澳大利亚飞往新西兰的途中，它还会莫名其妙地失去动力，在短短一秒钟内下坠500英尺。
airplane you you should you should appreciate the fact that it can fly and the fact that it does is pretty amazing I mean the fact that this tin can is floating in the sky at 40,000 feet that's pretty amazing that's's wild. But if you stop paying attention to it and you don't try and constantly improve it, then the doors might fall off and the landing gears might fail. And the wheels fall off and it also inexplicably will lose power when it's traveling from Australia to New Zealand and fall 500 feet in a second.
关键是，我明白你的意思，但这就跟性爱一样。这就好比哪怕过程很糟糕，它也依然是性爱，对吧？伙计们，我们真要这么说吗？当然，对。我们真要采纳这个说法吗？我的意思是，这是我们让特雷弗去签名的最后一条金句吗？等我们录完之后，我们或许还可以再打磨一下这个比喻。我需要好好消化一下这句话。
The point is, I get what you're saying, but it's like sex too. It's like even when it's bad, it's still sex, right? Guys, are we saying that? Sure, yeah. Are we gonna go with that? I mean, is that the last thing we're gonna get Trevor to go sign? We could probably workshop that one a little bit after we're done. I'll need to digest that one.
特雷弗，你已经超出规定时间九分钟了，对此我深表歉意。我们爱你。我们谢谢你。真是个该死的开心果。绝对的开心果。嘿，特雷弗，把你的电话号码给我，我们一起出去玩吧。我们应该这么做。等我去的时候我告诉你。不过其实，因为你是个利物浦球迷，还是个F1车迷，
Trevor, you are nine minutes over your obligated time, and I apologize for that. We love you. we thank you. What a fucking delight. What an absolute delight. Hey Trevor, let me get your number, let's hang out. We should do that. I'll let you know when I'm in. But actually, because you're a Liverpool fan and an F1 fan,
所以我们其实真该一起出去玩。我……你知道的，我们可以一起看比赛，就算我们一句话都不说，也会过得很开心。他这人还真不错。我们其实真的应该去，而且我实际上也会这么做。我真的会的。我喜欢这样，谢谢。好的。好吧。
like we actually should hang out. I'll, you know, we can just watch the things, and then even if we say nothing, we had a good time. He's not a bad hand. We actually should, and I actually will do it. I actually will. I like that, thank you. Okay. All right.
谢谢你，先生。一切都很顺利。希望不久后能再见到你。在此之前，谢谢。是的，非常感谢邀请我。上帝保佑，也许吧？这真的很酷。是的，谢谢你，特雷弗。
Thank you, sir. Everybody went all right. Hopefully I see you again soon. Until then, thank you. Yeah, thank you so much for having me. God bless, maybe? This is really cool. Yeah, thank you, Trevor.
很高兴认识你。在非洲，我们习惯说：上帝保佑，愿辛巴永远陪伴在你身边。哇，这正是我刚才想的。辛巴。我觉得他在开玩笑，但我决定当真了。我决定相信他的话。
Nice to get to know you. We say, in Africa, we say, God bless, and may Simba always be by your side. Wow, that's exactly what I was thinking. Simba. I feel like he's kidding, but I'm gonna take him at his word. I'm gonna take him at his word.
谢谢，谢谢。谢谢你，特雷弗。约堡见。祝你今天余下的时间过得愉快。谢谢你，特雷弗。再见。再见，老兄。好吧，你知道的，听着，我跟你说，
Thank you, thank you. Thanks, Trev. See you in Joburg. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, Trevor. Bye. Bye, buddy. Well, that, you know, listen, I'll tell you what,
这绝对是我们最棒的嘉宾之一。我真的很喜欢那个特雷弗·诺亚。我真的很喜欢他。行了，冷静点，冷静点。不，我知道。你已经名花有主了，他也是。不，我知道。我觉得他是个特别的家伙。
our best guest at times. I really like that Trevor Noah. I really like him. Yeah, cool it, cool it. No, I know. You were spoken for and so is he all the way. No, I know. I think that he's a special dude.
我真的很喜欢他。对，他非常聪明。一开始我对他一无所知。我只是觉得自己是个粉丝。道个歉。什么？对，我得向他道歉。但他氛围太棒了。对，他很聪明。一开始我对他一无所知，我只是通过一个……道个歉。对，我向他道歉了。但他有……我们甚至都还没来得及……我太喜欢和他聊天了，
I really like him. Yeah, he's very smart. Like, I didn't know anything about him. I just thought I was a fan. Apologize. What? Yeah, I apologize to him. But he a great vibe. Yeah, he's smart. Like I didn't know anything about him. I just thought I was a fan just from one. Apologize. Yeah, I apologize to him. But he's got, we didn't even, I love talking to him so much,
我们甚至都没聊到他在Spotify上的播客。他在Spotify上的播客叫《现在怎么办》（What Now），好吗？《现在怎么办》？《现在怎么办》？《现在怎么办》？就在Spotify上。他现在正在进行世界巡演。门票一直卖到11月份。
we didn't even get to his podcast on Spotify. His podcast on Spotify is called What Now, okay? What Now? What Now? What Now? And that's on Spotify. And he's on tour right now, like all over the world. And tickets are on sale through November.
所以如果你在新加坡、斯德哥尔摩、哥本哈根、法国、德国、鹿特丹、奥克兰、墨尔本……我的意思是，这家伙到处飞。他简直就像一个真正的国际超级巨星。对，对。喜剧巨星。真正的……对。喜剧巨星。货真价实。我们认识的大多数喜剧演员，
So if you're in Singapore, Stockholm, Copenhagen, France, Germany, Rotterdam, Auckland, Melbourne, I mean, the guy is hopping all over. He's like a real international superstar. Yeah, yeah. Comedy superstar. The real yeah. Comedy superstar. The real deal. Most of the comedians that we know
都是我们的朋友，我们也深爱着他们，但他们全特么去了丹佛、奥马哈之类的地方，对吧，就像一群该死的笨蛋一样，对吧？但你看看特雷弗·诺亚，他在新加坡。我们所有该死的美国笨蛋喜剧演员都可以去吃屎了。只有特雷弗在世界各地到处跑，去各种地方，对吧？真成熟。
who are our friends who we adore, but they're all going to fucking Denver and Omaha and shit, right, like a bunch of fucking ding-dongs, right? But then you got Trevor Ngoan, he's in Singapore. All our fucking stupid American comedian friends can suck it. Just, Trevor's out in the world, places, right? Sophisticated.
他很有见识。他很有见识，做着很酷的事情。是的，我喜欢和别人聊天。仅仅通过这样一次简短的闲聊，我就能学到这么多东西。我还在回味他最近演出的那个城市。你们还记得那个城市的名称吗？哦，来了，来了，来了。
He's sophisticated. He's sophisticated, doing cool shit. Yeah, I like talking to people. I learn so much just from a quick hang like that. I've also been thinking about that city he performed at recently. Do you guys remember the name of that city? Oh, here comes, here comes, here comes.
你已经急着要收尾了吗？我们甚至还没怎么聊够他呢。你想说什么，莫尔？我太喜欢他了。他超级聪明。我想让他再来一次，这样我能学到更多。他对自己的离开很兴奋。让他去吧。肖恩，你刚才在说什么？好吧，那是一个很多富人居住的地方。
Are you trying to wrap it up already? We've barely talked about him. What do you want to say, Moore? I love him. He's super smart. I want him to come back so I can learn more. He's excited about his bye. Let him get to it. What were you talking about, Sean? Well, it's a place where a lot of rich people live.
那是哪儿？迪拜！天哪，这个梗他已经在心里憋了半小时了。真聪明。迪拜！天哪，这个梗他已经在心里憋了半小时了。迪拜！真聪明。少废话。真聪明。少废话。
Where's that? Dubai! God, he's had that loaded for a half hour. Smart. Do-fi! God, he's had that loaded for a half hour. Do-fi! Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
《SmartLess》由贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿姆贾夫（Rob Armjarff）100%有机纯手工打造。如果你喜欢《SmartLess》，现在就可以加入Wondry App或苹果播客上的Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告版。Prime会员可以在亚马逊音乐上收听无广告版。在离开之前，请前往 wondery.com/survey 填写简短问卷，让我们更好地了解你。骗子们最广为人知的往往是过着穷奢极欲的生活，直到东窗事发，才被迫用一副手铐和一套橙色囚服换回这一切。
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff. If you like Smartless, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wondery.com slash survey. Scammers are best known for living the high life until they're forced to trade it all in for handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit once they're finally caught.
我是萨奇·科尔。我是莎拉·哈吉。我们是《诈骗风云》（Scamfluencers）的主持人，这是一档来自Wondry的每周播客，将带你了解历史上一些最臭名昭著的骗局的曲折内幕、它们对受害者造成的影响，以及当光鲜的外表褪去后留下了什么。我们报道过各种故事，比如某个通过《创智赢家》认证的企业家，虽然带着投资离开了节目，但很快就面临如山的账单、拉里·金发起的集体诉讼，却没有真正的产品来推销。于是他转而捕食
I'm Saatchi Cole. And I'm Sarah Hagge. And we're the host of Scamfluencers, a weekly podcast from Wondery that takes you along the twists and turns of some of the most infamous scams of all time, the impact on victims, and what's left once a facade falls away. We've covered stories like a Shark Tank certified entrepreneur who left the show with an investment, but soon faced mounting bills, an active lawsuit filed by Larry King, and no real product to push. He then began to prey on
脆弱的女性，向她们兜售对未来的美好憧憬，却在她们背后偷走她们的财产。还有《娇妻》明星特雷莎·朱迪斯（Teresa Giudice）等人的臭名昭著的骗局，原本应该证明是她人生的重大滑铁卢，却似乎反而巩固了她在《娇妻》名人堂中的地位。
vulnerable women instead, selling the idea of a future together while stealing from them behind their backs. To the infamous scams of Real Housewives stars like Teresa Giudice, what should have proven to be a major downfall only seemed to solidify her place in the Real Housewives Hall of Fame.
在Wondry App或你获取播客的任何地方订阅《诈骗风云》。你现在就可以在Wondry+上提前收听无广告版的《诈骗风云》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Follow Scamfluencers on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Scamfluencers early and ad free right now on Wondry+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Wondry App或您获取播客的任何地方关注Scamfluencers。您现在可以在Wondry+上提前且无广告地收听Scamfluencers。本集目前没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。